[inaudible] to server.
Ah, recording discernment.
The Joe Rogan experience. I almost said
it again. I will say the Joe rogan.net.
Is that because I'm a fucking
idiot bro. Why? Asking questions.
He known me for years.
The Joe Rogan experience podcast is
brought to you by the fleshlight.
If you go to Joe rogan.net and click on
the link for the flashlight and enter in
the code name Rogan,
you will save 15% on the
number one sex toy for men.
And it does feel good. Doug Benson,
you've never fucked one of those.
I still haven't done that. I got one
for Ya. It's on my bucket list. Well,
I'm giving you a new one tonight.
Here we go. Bitches buckle up.
Doug Vance is in the house.
Doctor Joe,
you're on fucking deep in trouble.
Cool.
So, so fitting that my good friend
Doug Benson is here with me today.
Most rock and music of any
podcasts probably. Is it the
most rocking? Yeah. Every,
everyone else's songs are like cute or
they're just sort of like a, you know,
they sound like alternative comedy
would sound if it were music,
alternative comedy with
side of it was music.
Something to nod your head off and
the drive off the road into a tree.
Something kind of folky,
maybe poppy,
but that that really wakes you up here
is really rocks and it was too loud in my
headphones that that
boom, boom, boom. Yeah,
that's just to let you know you're
not supposed to be comfortable always.
Sometimes the, the, the
beauty that comes afterwards,
you would appreciate it more
because he went through those drums.
That's what I'm saying, right?
Yeah. You're startled and then,
and then it's soothing and then it's like
okay, he's not going to do that again.
And that's Joey Diaz is here and then
poor Brian and scrambling every five
seconds reaching for the volume dial.
Wait,
we have to eventually get compression
like a, the great Adam Carolla his,
his setup is so, so bad ass.
I had total podcasts envy.
I went over to his set up
and he's got like real staff.
He's got a crew of people working there.
There was like five,
six people working in this,
all this electronics and equipment and
video switches and, and I'm like, wow,
you sit on a couch. Yeah. Did Jesus
better though? We did the couch.
This is way better for,
for the folks in iTunes.
We used to do what we used to have this
stupid fucking z Gallerie couch that I
bought and I just figured, well, let's
just say, make a comment about that.
But the problem is the couches are only
good if someone's staring opposite.
You have,
you're sitting back and relaxing and
someone's on the other side of the room,
but an office chair is way better.
It's pretty much more supportive. Yeah.
So we go back, we have a circular
table now in an office chair.
This is as much as we,
we started out with just a laptop.
So this is a big incidents.
This,
it's like we came to the table to do some
business. He had a fucking, we're not,
we're not here to just sit back and fuck
around. We are here to do some business.
Dr Drew. Oh my God, dude, you're
shocked. You're so bad at doctor drew.
It's upsetting to me because I know that
he knows what he's saying is not true.
I know that he,
what he's saying is
sensationalist nonsense that
he's saying because he hopes it
will either get people like me to
pay attention and no, he's not.
I know he's sincere about it.
I think he's doing it to get ratings.
He's doing it to be a certain guy.
It's not what he's saying.
This is what he's saying,
Brian,
to this fucking thing up because somebody
tweeted me this today and I just sat
there with my mouth open,
shaking my head going, this is a,
this is a nonsense argument, man. This
is a stupid argument. Listen to this.
This is about a bust in Florida.
Real 21
get out, but I've jumped in
pretty say to you, how dare you?
How dare you think he's my friend?
You'd be good to him. Okay.
We're keeping drug counselor Shelley's
Sprague with us for this next story.
28 Palm Beach County high school students
were caught by surprise when they were
arrested.
In a drug sting in Florida.
The nine month investigation was called
Operation d minus undercover officers
posed as students, befriended the kids
and allegedly brought pop from them.
The suspects in the case of
course it need not be set,
are innocent until proven guilty,
but watch this.
Marijuana is a
drug.
The THC content and marijuana
these days would be improved.
Growing methods is much stronger than
many years ago.
Down to that,
I want to live long enough to see you
at the time when it's not necessary.
We're going to keep doing it as long as we
drove down this room.
I actually agree with these guys though.
I'm always cast as the NARC.
I'm not a NARC. I'm not interested in
telling you about how to live their life,
but I'm interested in the health of
young people and this kind of thing is a
good idea. Don't you think, Shelly? Hey,
do I think that keeping drugs out of
schools at these formative ages are
important and pushing the age of
exposure to college age and above,
I think is important.
I think that there's a lot of
misinformation about pot out there.
There's this weird cultural ener energy
around the drug and people are unwilling
to accept the fact that it's addictive.
It's a different pot than it was 20
years ago. It's absolutely different.
There's withdrawal syndromes,
the involved with it. Um, and,
and I just think people
have so much misinformation.
I consistently hear people undereducated
about what's going on in the drug
cultures of today and, and the, you
know, keeping up with the bath salts,
keeping up with marijuana,
keeping up with all of these changes,
legislation changes. I mean, it's
a full time job, surely. Thank you.
It's always good to see here.
Appreciate it.
And I want to just emphasize
the fact that cannabis,
according to the American
Society of addiction medicine,
not just me and Shelly,
and I see this all the time,
is addictive.
It's one of the more common
things we treat the these days.
It has a rather severe withdrawal
center associated with it.
And the addictive process is
always the same with cannabis.
It's somebody who uses just a couple
times and then has this, oh my God,
experiences is the greatest thing ever.
And then preoccupies and uses every
day thereafter, somewhere out there,
months or years later, it stops working
so well. They start getting irritable,
paranoid,
not so high anymore.
They use a lot more to try to bring the
high back and that's when they get into
very serious trouble with the dog and
switch to else like what worries me is
bath salts.
Tonight was a really interesting night.
Please take note about the bath salts.
They are out there.
If you or someone you love was getting
exposed to substances get help.
The sad thing about Corey story is
that he had, this is a treatable thing,
completely treatable and he needed
to be walking around in dangerous,
the dangerous condition he is in. Now,
I also want to say that our whole,
our hopes and wishes are out there
for Maria Shriver. Kill that.
What his hopes and wishes are
over Maria Shriver, you whore,
you whore. They get through
these terrible times. You whore.
Your heritage hasn't been a living
hell for the last 20 years. That has a,
that's horror. Like doctor drew,
I love you, but you're a whore.
I just have to call you out, dude.
This is nonsense talk you say so he,
first of all,
what he's saying is that marijuana is a
lot of information there and marijuana
is higher today than ever. Both
for, well, yes it is. It's better.
Here's the real statistics.
Okay. You Ready? A long time ago,
back in the 1970s the THC content of the
average marijuana was less than 1% it
was weak ass, shitty weed, the
average weed. But since Amelia,
if you get some high potent shit,
it's as high as 30% 14 to
30% and was back then too.
You could find some bad motherfuckers
back then they got some shit and they
brought it up from South America and
it'll blow your fucking socks off.
That's a fact.
Yeah.
The WAC weed back then is weaker than
the Wac we'd today the whack we today is
about 5% okay.
But the really strong stuff gets 30
32 34 if you've got some crazy shit.
So it's slightly higher for
the highest grade stuff.
And the reason why is because there's
a lot of scientists and botanists.
Heres the point.
There's no bodies.
No one's dying from this
extra potent weed. You know
what? This extra potent weed,
it's getting you higher,
easier.
You don't have to take two hits instead
of six back then they would smoke a
whole joint because the joint was made
at a dog. Shit, it was terrible weed.
So this is stupid, stupid
argument. Second of all,
him saying that it's physically addictive
and that there's withdrawal symptoms.
Look, there's withdrawal
symptoms from gambling, okay?
And there's withdrawal symptoms from video
games and there's withdrawal symptoms.
Cough, coffee, coffees, way worse. That's
a physical withdrawal. You, you'll shit,
you're shaking if you don't get your
coffee, if you don't get your weed,
you're like, oh, bummer.
And Him citing whatever fucking government
organization that measures addictive
drugs. Guess what, man? That's
all. All that stuff is nonsense.
There's no real studies being done on how
much marijuana withdrawals affects the
average person and they're not putting
people through marijuana and measuring
them. Here's the people that have
problems with pot ready, losers.
The people that problem with pot, and
this was in one of my jokes is one of my,
one of my cds. But it's true.
If Pot fucked up your life,
it's just cause pot got there first.
Okay. It could've been cheeseburgers,
scratch tickets,
the horse races.
If folks have a plant
that makes you look at
the world in a more humble way, it makes
food taste better. It makes you silly.
It makes you want to love your
friends more, make sex better,
makes food taste better.
If that fucks up your life,
you are an idiot and it's that simple.
And doctor Jews not doing anybody any
favors and giving idiots a little bandaid
for their fucking mental problems because
that's what this is three of our last
three presidents who all admitted to
having smoked marijuana. He would,
they're suggesting that they should
have been arrested in high school for
getting involved with it.
It's really,
it makes no sense is so he's right in a
way that I don't like the idea of drugs
in high school because kids
don't know what the fuck.
They're not making an educated choice
and they're not making it about Ponte.
They're not making it about coke.
They're not making it about all
kinds of shit that comes our way.
And a lot of fucking sometimes in
high school is tough enough, man.
I don't advocate you doing anything you
don't feel like you're comfortable with.
I did a lot of shit in high school.
I smoked weed and high school.
I got drunk and high school.
The drunk. Has he ever gotten,
nobody ever taught me how to drink. Nobody
ever taught me how much she can drink.
So I got super drunk with my friends,
threw up in a cab and I get,
why aren't we sending people undercover
to stop kids from drinking in schools?
Yeah,
no shit man.
Because it's that not more than 28 why
do we leap frog to a weed which causes a
lot less problems with the kid
in their overall lives? Right.
And who are these hormone lists bitches
posing as cops that can actually pretend
to be 17 and an infiltrate this
school. Oh, what the fuck. Meanwhile,
if the kids they're infiltrating
were probably too high to notice.
There were 40 beards and shit
and the canes people to fucking,
yeah, liver spots. Why does
Linda have a walker? She's full.
She's only 16 and what are the
symptoms that they're talking about?
They send the addiction study,
whatever that was.
What are the addictions that movies suck?
Listen, man, it's real simple. Physically.
It's not the drug that addicts to you.
It doesn't clean to your body.
You can get mentally addicted to it,
but you can get mentally ill addicted
to every single thing on this earth.
There's people that are addicted
literally to washing their hands.
You can call it obsessive
compulsive disorder.
I call it being addicted to his
particular set of activities.
And that's what it is, man.
People are fucking weird.
Comforts you. Yes, for what?
You know, whatever weird thing
it is you do over and over again.
It's because it's something you enjoy
doing. You know, we're human beings.
We don't repeat things over and
over again because we hate it.
Sometimes we do that.
Well,
you know an accident pick scabs
and your movie you didn't.
That's the worst smoke weed
for 30 days and you're moving.
Do you have any withdrawal symptoms
when you're in it? Well, you know,
people would argue watching the
movie that I got cranky but,
but you know, I think I was just
basically myself cause I certainly,
if something irritates me when I'm
high, it's still irritating. You know,
it's not like you're just suddenly
this, hey, everything's fine.
Poke me with a stick. I don't give a
shit. I'm high. It's not, you're like,
you're just, you know, your head's
in another place but you're not,
you're not gone. You know, like
the whole thing with alcohol,
the way that, uh, you know,
people say racist stuff after
they get drunk, you know,
like it's not a lot of people were
getting high and then just, you know,
suddenly dropping the n word in
a, in a smoking circle, you know,
it's a totally different vibe.
It's,
if anything,
cigarettes are the thing they
should be spending the most time on.
Because I fucking started smoking when
I was 15 and it was easy to get fucking
cigarettes.
I didn't fucking buy cigarettes from
some guy in the back of a fucking alley.
I went to a store and not like nine
out of 10 times I could buy cigarettes.
Yeah,
I don't,
I don't fault him for
talking about a lot of drugs.
There's a lot of drugs that are dangerous
as fuck and we should talk about
crystal meth all day long.
You should tell people don't do it.
You're going to ruin everything. It will
ruin your life. We need to tell, you know.
Yeah.
I've never heard doctor drew lumpin
we'd with everything else like bad,
like yeah,
we'd and bath salts like there,
like there's any connection between the,
the two things
like legal and but crazy. Terrible
for you. Yeah. If you don't know it.
Bath salts are, there's a thing
and we talked about on the podcast,
we were incorrect.
We had to go back and correct ourselves.
We thought that what they were doing was
selling stuff as bath salts or you can
get high with,
what they're doing is it's a drug and
they're just labeling it bath salts to
allow people to buy it legally.
But they have no intention
of using it for bath salts.
It's like some sort of secret little
loophole they figured out how to do and
this drug,
it's like a cousin to crystal Meth,
so technically it's not
illegal and there's,
there's laws that they've established
to try to get like close neighbors and
cousins of drugs out and that's
how they got rid of five Meo DMT,
which was legal for the longest time.
Five meo DMT,
which is stronger than regular
DMT somehow or another slip by.
They're all encompassing psychedelic,
the act of 1970 and that you could buy
it online through a chemical company and
get a big jar of it and shit.
We should just start calling.
We had candy or something.
We should just give it a name of
something that's legal. Herbal Salad.
Speaking of verbal salad, Brian's dog ate
his weed or let's call it lean cuisine.
That's, that's apparently that's
legal to push that shit on people.
How does that work?
Yeah, there's the, yeah,
go after these diet pills.
Easy and smooth.
Lose the weight with no work at
all. This is a lie. You're lying,
you're stealing people's money.
There's nothing like that.
Buying a shitload of weed and
then having your dog eat it.
So we need to get to get into any
of it. Your dog is a mess, man.
Your dog is a slide.
Your dog needs to go on.
Dr Drew's show for dogs for
everything, for everything. For Sex,
for weed. This doctor drew thing though,
does, is it not? Is it driving you crazy?
It's driving me crazy. Well, it's a kind
of weird because I've heard Dr drew in,
in his recently as a year
or so, say things like, uh,
he told Adam once in one of their
podcasts together that he thinks that
marijuana will be legalized in our
lifetimes. He thinks it's inevitable.
So I don't know why he would think that
and then also be talking this way about
it.
And uh,
I've also heard him say that
it's a alcohol is addictive
to someone who already
is an addict. Like they're already,
they're going to be addicted to something.
And so, I mean, marijuana, you
said alcohol. I said, yeah,
I'm saying alcoholics are,
can get addicted to weed was kind of
the point he was making. Oh, I see.
What you said is that a, you kind
of have to be in an addict to, uh,
to treat we'd that way. And it
could be something, it could,
might as well be something else.
So by saying it's addictive,
it's just addictive to, there's some
people that have a certain predilection,
what's the word? Yeah,
whatever. They, they're,
they're predisposed to addiction. So it
would be alcohol. It could be anything.
Yeah. Yeah. They're an alcoholic who
smokes too much weed or whatever.
We do have a friend that, that is, uh, he,
he used to do coke and all kinds of
other crazy stuff and now he's like super
clean and healthy. And he told me
he can't smoke joints. He can't.
He literally can't. He said I would
love to get high, but if I get high,
I know it's just going to be coke and
then it's going to be whatever the fuck
else I can get. And before
you know it, um, you know,
I'm waking up at someone's house. I
don't know how it got there. Right.
And you can say the same thing about
alcohol or anything else. They like,
you have to know your limits and uh,
but somehow we're allowed to decide
what our limits are and alcohol. Yeah.
And when we're not allowed to decide
what our limits are with weed,
which is way more than though not fair,
which is way, way physically super Jaime,
I stopped drinking for 60 days and it
still was performing in clubs every night
and either being not high or high and
when I'm not high or high, I like a drink.
Right. You know what I mean? So 60 days,
if not drinking was the hardest thing.
Really. No way I take that
back. For the sperm test,
I had to not masturbate for like three
or four days. So that was the hardest.
That was the hardest part in
60 days in the first place.
Then the second place is 60 days
and Obas and third place and far,
far third place was 30 days
of not smoking, which was
a pretty easy thing to do.
I could do it again tomorrow.
I'm not going to,
cause I've already proved this point.
I could,
I could go again for 30 days very easily.
Like if somebody stepped up and said,
we'll give you $1 million to go
30 days, no sweat. I take it back,
we'll give you $500 and a trip
to Disney world, I can do it.
You know, it just has to be something
that I love. Like, uh, you know,
I'll forget to smoke weed for a day here
and there. I'll just be like, oh, that's,
but it's not like during the day I'm
thinking about it. You know, you're like,
that's the thing. You can get
busy and forget to smoke. Yeah.
Have withdrawal symptoms of like, shit,
I need a taste. Yeah. Yeah. Well, I,
you know,
for most people,
let's say 90 whatever
percent of the population,
marijuana is not physically addictive.
If it is physically addictive,
some small percentage of the population
we need, that's a medical issue.
We need to figure out what's wrong with
the other person or tests have never
been done because it's a schedule
one narcotic, right? Yeah.
So that means they can't even test test
it. It's, it's the most ridiculous.
We need this in this crazy
sell they can't get out of.
Because you know,
old people and TV commentators need to
all just go away because young people do
not care. Young guilty, do not care about
weed. They don't care about gay marriage.
They don't care about a lot of these
issues that are being thrown around right
now that young people are just,
whatever these numbers should we do you
want have been around since I was a baby,
when I was a child.
I was 11 years old.
My family moved from San Francisco to
Florida and when we lived at San Francisco
came, people were
everywhere. San Francisco,
this squeak weekend with Cobb's
comedy club, but Sam [inaudible],
Sam Tripoli and Tom Segura Thompson era.
It's tickets are almost sold out anyway.
Um, when, when we were in San Francisco,
we tried to work one of those in later.
Just shove it in there, bro. And AAA is
an awesome, I mean, rather San Francisco.
I enjoy the shit out of San Francisco
when I lived there. And a triple.
He's an awesome guy too,
but that's beside that.
That's a great center on a wrong path.
I lived next to some gay people and they
were cool as fuck and they used to get
naked with my aunt. She used to go
over, they would play bongos together.
I've told the story and they would
smoke weed and so gay people to me,
you have a drink. Gave people to me
were just like, this guy is black.
This guy's giving me, this guy is
from Guatemala. This guy is Chinese.
It's just a different,
why do you have to blacks and
Guatemalans and Chinese like that, dude,
I did and I pumped them up. Yeah,
it's, yeah, it's all the same.
It's one that says that's what
young people think that you know,
the young people are really in the
melting pot because every kid is half this
and half of that these days.
You know his parents though,
there's more and more of all the
ethnicities. It's growing, you know? Yeah.
This country is really
going to change drastically.
But this argument of them being able to
be married, it's been going on forever.
When I was 11 we had moved from San
Francisco to Florida and I was hanging out
with my friend,
candy Esposito.
Candy was a Cuban kid and his dad was
yelling and throwing the paper down and we
walked in the room and I was like,
fuck, what happened? You know,
and this guy's mad.
Some shit must have went down.
And so someone says what happened? And he
goes, fucking fags, want to get married.
He believed this shit and he's holding
up a newspaper. And I'm like, wow.
And I'm 11 and I'm looking at this guy,
I'm going,
I don't believe this mother Fucker's
a dad. And I was thinking like,
thank God you know this,
this asshole isn't guiding me in life.
He's sitting here getting angry and
throwing his newspaper down like a fool
because some gay guys want to get married.
So that was like fucking,
I was 11 I'm 43 do the math.
That's a long ass time ago and
it's still going on. Hang on.
I need a pen and paper.
I have to do the math 40 32 but you
won't have to do any math at my show on
Sunday at flappers in
Burbank,
California for 20 in the afternoon show.
And if you're doing,
if you're after and you're going out
of town, right? Yeah. What Day is this?
This Sunday? Sunday. Sunday. I
might be back not doing Sunday,
Thursday, Friday, Saturday and
I fly back. I might do that.
I might go to your show that often
because I have to. Yeah, I might do that.
I flying in at like 9:00
AM so yeah, it's, you know,
it's my interruption podcast.
Oh, you're doing a podcast.
But we did a comic out and we just
basically fuck around for a few minutes,
read some tweets and talk about stuff.
I mean it's like basically what we're
doing right now, but with an audience,
I don't, I don't really heckle
you as much as you just, you know,
just fuck around together. Yeah.
Yeah. It's like an interview,
but you're standing and I'm sitting and
flappers is perfect. Been awesome menu.
Their food there is so delicious.
So if you go there,
study the thing I'm trying to,
I've been trying to tell them as they're
going to sell a lot of food that that
afternoon they should batten
the hatches or you know,
whatever expression you should tired
their lines at what point in time,
just the four 20 thing become hacky. Does
it get to a certain point? We, you know,
when you see a dude's cross screen name
on your message board, it's Doug for 20.
Oh,
that guy's probably an idiot.
It's like if you've got a girls' email
address and her an email addresses,
you know, whatever,
you know, uh, you know,
Barbara 69,
that girl's a slut,
you know what I'm saying?
Or at least that's certainly the
impression she wants to give off.
She wants to let you
know there's that action.
People are proud of smoking thought I,
I'm proud of it too, but I've never,
I've never really tried to put
it front and center. You know,
it sort of became that. We tried to put
it for you did the marijuana logs? No.
I mean, but the jokes were
like, you know, they weren't,
it wasn't like a OneNote show.
We went off in lots of
different directions.
Got To say that you put marijuana
pretty front and center though dude.
And it's a good thing in terms of that.
Yeah,
I wrote a play a play about
it with two other dudes,
but like we just all just happen to have
pot jokes in our acts and then we're
like let's just pull them together.
So we did,
we wrote a little bit of extra material
but I'm just saying that like pot jokes,
I've always been in my act just cause
then I'm honest about it and it's part of
my life. So that's why it was there and
then people liked it. So then you know,
you obviously talk more about the
things that people want to hear about.
It's a thing where people who don't smoke
pot get upset at people that smoke a
lot of pot and talk a lot about
it all the time. They get upset.
I know lots of people don't find
it to be interesting conversation.
And the reason we like it is
because we're high. You know. So I,
I've had that problem with people out
on the road. He said I'm a different,
I'm on a different level than they are
for my enthusiasm for talking about weed.
Cause obviously I already
have to talk about it a lot.
So somebody comes up to me and they
want to talk about movies or something.
I'm kind of excited because
everybody just wants to say,
what's your favorite strain? You
know, have you ever been to Amsterdam?
And that Shit's fun to talk
about. But it's like, you know,
just gets repetitive and you know,
and also they want to do a lot of
the talking. So you go, there's,
you have to do a lot of listening
sometimes, which is, you know, yeah.
They want to tell you if
they can be fun sometimes.
But like remember I remember the guy at
the end of the line and I'm in Toronto
that had some conspiracy theory for them.
We talked about, oh that's so funny.
He was young. It was crazy.
You saw that back me up.
How crazy it was that done. Yeah,
that was wild. I mean, I was like,
eventually I was like, Joe, we got to,
um, you know, we have this thing to go.
The bouncer was pulling him away and
he's like, no, you don't understand.
I have to communicate with them this
information. It was like grabbing him,
pulling him away. It's like,
no, no, no, I'm, I'm going to
stay. I have to talk to him.
See the email I posted? Yes. It's fucking
ridiculous. The most ridiculous. Yeah.
But you know,
it was just one of a million.
There's a million guys
out there like that.
And it's because of me talking
about psychedelic drugs
and talking about DMT and
weed and stuff like that. I get these
people, they find me like a magnet.
The only thing that keeps you from being
more aggressive about it is because I'm
a comedian and I'm kind of talk
about them. Probably black plastic.
Play the podcast on the schizo radio
channel on Sirius. There's a skid.
So radio check. What are you talking
to me? This is what it seems like that,
that the, the guy from, uh, was
it, uh, uh, shit. Labrea no,
I know one of the local California
clubs. You remember the, there,
there was a guy that came up that thought
we recorded and it was like we weren't
going to put it online
because it was too crazy,
but it sounded like the same guy
that you just talked to recorded.
What are you talking about? Uh, some guy
came up to you in line. You used to stone,
right?
Completely lost you.
Some guy came in line with what
you were signing autographs.
I don't know if you remember him.
He came up to you and start
talking like he was like, uh Oh,
I know what you're talking about.
Yeah, it was in, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And I didn't want to talk about
it. It's too annoying. Yeah,
but it seems like you have like this
whole like weird group of people.
You're going to get that man.
Doug gets that too.
You're going to end anytime when
you're in any sort of a public forum,
whether it's a podcast,
a TV show, anything.
There's eyes on you and as
a certain amount of them
are not going to be healthy.
That was the most horrible
sentence structure I ever
did since the, by the way,
sorry, you might be retarded. You
ain't want to go to a doctor. You know,
you know who, who's retarded. If you guys
followed any of these la reporters, uh,
like, like the news in La
is completely different than
like, uh, like news in Ohio.
Like I was watching something the
other day and I found it online.
This is a on the shake weight and
you know the shake weight thing that,
that South Park and everyone dies,
right where the shake where it
looks like you've eaten off.
This is morning news in La. Okay.
Just listen to how crazy this is.
A visual thing or see the infomercial.
Maybe you've seen it. Parody and uh,
they're called shake
weights while she's talking.
The guys using it there now the
focus of a brand, he's holding it.
That is right.
Allan Mckay is shaking with excitement
at the prospect of taking part of this
new shake weight class. An alley sounds
good. Dog to go slow or better to go fast.
Get the point. I think you and
you kind of bury it, bury it.
You don't know how you're, you're
doing, what's that noise man?
That's sound effect.
They can have a little mirror on the top.
Is that where the cooldown
spray comes out? No,
actually all on south park but brought
that up and it went out live mode.
Trains.
Yeah.
It's mark here and they asked me to
join in but I've got a small white one
because I make a difference.
No,
I don't actually think
it's the size of it.
It's actually the technique
and Kay, thank you. Thank you.
Come attracting tracking
that at all of men at home.
We're wondering that as well.
Not Chris Cause he,
he told me he had the
big black one. Yeah, he
says they pretty much had it.
Well it goes on a little bit more.
Nothing too funny by they go on like they
actually said that he has a big black
dick the whole time.
The black reporters like shaking it super.
Ever do a morning TV when you're
on the road. No, I stopped.
It was too ridiculous. So silly. It's on.
It's like you're in a sketch about a bad
TV show about censorship and oh yeah.
It's about how you can't,
yeah, yeah. They're not even
a little crazy little edgy.
There's no edginess and like they get
this look, as soon as you get edgy,
they get this look in their eye.
You know the hosts,
they just like are flipping
out. Yeah, I stopped doing them.
They're just too ridiculous.
You know?
I was doing a fast to give you a really
long lined up and then they ask you one
question and by the time
you're done with your answer,
your interviews almost over it. Yeah.
And you do radio before that, like God,
all that stuff is so much this. It's, it's
so much less fun than doing a podcast.
You know the the best that thing about
the podcast and one of the reasons why
these conversations get so weird and go
and sort of so many different places is
when we don't have a particular start
or stop time. It just kind of goes,
there's not like some commercial
you got to insert in there.
There's not some break.
We have to take,
there's not some boss we have to answer
to. There's not some code of words Cunt,
nigger. You can say whatever you want. You
can just keep going. It doesn't matter.
I saw one of those the other day. I
can't nigger. What did it look like?
Describe it to me. Did it
have high heels? Purple? Um,
I'd imagine it would have like high heels,
like an an our chrom comic book. Yeah.
Yeah, totally. At high heels.
I'm trying to, yes and, but I didn't, I
didn't really see one of those. You could,
you know, you could do things today
that you could never do back then.
Back then in the old days of comedy when
he had to go to local radio stations,
it was always so painful.
But the worst part about it was the,
the TV shows for sure. Cause
they would be, you know,
what you'd have like what's the most
you've ever done on one, seven minutes,
eight minutes, right. Yeah.
And it's just, it's just there.
They asked that, you know,
they want, they ask questions that
don't lead to humorous answers.
Where are you from? You know, unless
you've got a chunk about, in my case,
San Diego,
I just always go,
I'm from San Diego and then
they'd say something like, Oh,
it's beautiful down there. Were
you a fan of the Padres? Yeah.
Used to go see if you're getting,
you know,
like you're not getting it anywhere
funny you, you kind of have to take over.
Like I always just pick something that's
going on there and just start running
on it right immediately. Like what's with
this guy over here? Yes. Kind of stuff.
Cause and just make it like,
oh this guy's crazy.
We can't even have a conversation with
him because that's all you can do to to
even be kind of funny. Yeah. You got
to sink the ship right away. Yeah.
I'm always like, if they had a
cooking segment, I'm eating whatever.
It was like I'm high out of my mind just
sitting there eating like this is good.
What's that? Your phone? Yeah.
Be like this is good right now.
Just get some cook it anymore.
Let's just eat.
I was in Kentucky and we got a me and
my feature at got interviewed by like a
guy,
like a serious news man looking dude
who was like in his 50s or 60s
named a, his name was uh, uh,
Barry Bernson and uh, and I remember
his name because it was just so amazing.
We went, Oh God, this interview
is going to be brutal.
And we sit down and the first
thing out of his mouth is,
did you know that marijuana is the
number one cash crop and Kentucky?
And I was like, [inaudible], I like it.
That is awesome that you would open up
with that question. And he was like,
you know, Mr Newsman
and he knew that. So he,
he put it in there and we had a
nice little discussion about it.
Is it the number one cash crop in
Kentucky? It's a number one in Hawaii too.
That's awesome. I wonder. He supposedly,
it's the number one the
country as far as couch.
Doug Stanhope hates the morning news
so bad that I remember when he did this
where he took a friend of his,
like the opener comic,
the local opener comic and
told him to go as Doug.
So the guy put on sunglasses
difference. Yeah, put sunglasses on.
Like I had a trench coat
and I taped the whole thing.
It's like 10 minutes long or something
like that where he goes through a car
show and he was like, we're here
with Doug Stanhope now. Doug,
how's it feel to be on the road and
stuff like that. The guys just like, Eh,
it feels amazing.
But you could pull that off because a
lot of times when you show up at a place,
no one, there is a fan, you
know, they're just like,
they're just doing their job and you know,
some publicists talked him into having
you or whatever and it's so fun.
It's really, it's really crazy doing those
things. I like to do those things with.
I like to bring cameras,
like if it's for super high me or the
documentary I did for GE for like,
it just adds that extra,
everyone kind of enhances their
performance a little bit, you know,
so like those radio people can look
even crazier or even, you know,
even a weirder than they actually are.
Whenever we do radio on the road.
We always do that. We did
in Austin, there's the last
place I do radio was Austin.
Just cause I love them. You
just, you sit and film it. Yeah.
We film it and then put it
on the Internet. We put it,
we have this little video blog that
we add along to this podcast thing.
Now we're expanding,
expanding our outreach and uh,
we just throw that stuff in there.
And you know, Brian did one in Austin,
the video, what was it called?
Austin Little Austin. A
little awesome. Something,
something like that. And
so yeah, it'd be a cap.
See Comedy Club in Austin
on June 1st and second
Dublin plugs.
You can't bring up a city with about
me having a gig coming up there. I'm,
I'm going everywhere. Oh yeah. Yeah. Cause
I just go places for a night or two now.
I don't do weekends in a pill
in the club. Ever. Ever, ever.
What did you start doing this?
Just like in the last year or so?
I just kind of figured it out. They're
like, especially in the winter time,
I only want to,
you know,
I'll just bop around Florida
and California and then
the rest of the year I just
hit everywhere else.
So what do you do for Friday and Saturday?
Sometimes we'll have a show, but it'd
be like in a rock club or something.
So I don't have to do, I don't have to
do to that night. It's cool. Really.
And when did you start doing this? So you
said a year and a half ago I would be,
you know, in the last,
it's been a transition,
but like this year I finally put my foot
down. I just like, unless it's like,
you know,
helium in Portland,
the last time I played there I
did five shows where there were,
nobody had said a peep
out of the audience.
They were the most amazing
crowds I ever played for. Yeah.
It was like when that was one of the last
weekends I was doing a full weekend in
a club.
So I consider doing that again there.
But I just don't like to show nights
because you always second show is always
going to be drunker, you know, I
like, I like people at eight o'clock.
I think that's a perfect time for people
to watch a comedy show and it'll be
done by 10 then go then go
get shit. Just, you know,
there's no reason to be shit
faced during the show, you know,
use that always ruins it. My people are
always going to be fucked up though. Yeah.
Well those people to accept a
certain level of fucked up and this,
cause I'm going to be fucked up too.
But I'm just saying that like it's easy
to like get really high and then go into
the comedy club and oh I got to get
a couple drinks. All right. You know,
give me something that they asked.
They asked for something that's you know,
too much and they, so they
ended up being, you know,
even worse than the typical
drunk. They're like, uh,
someone that doesn't drink that
much being drunk, you know,
you've broken these people down
psychologically. Yeah. It's really,
it's really interesting. Like, cause uh,
most of my audience is just
high and having a good time,
but like it's easy for, you
know, somebody to be like,
I get people come up to me
after shows all the time.
I'd never been to a comedy club before
and so I think the idea of like having to
have drinks is overwhelming and you
order like a long island ice tea or some
shit like that that like, you
know, you're going to be a man.
I don't have a straight after it.
You don't have a problem with people
being drunk. I like, I'm drunk.
It's definitely part of
the case difference part of
the game for sure. I don't,
I would never want to do a show
and I probably have done a few,
but I don't want to do a show where
there's no alcohol being served.
I've done the, I love the alcohol's
being served. I've done those. But yeah,
I agree. Yeah. I've been in like a, you
know, marijuana logs was in a theater,
so nobody was really
drinking. But um, but yeah, I,
but I just don't like the whole
comedy club thing of not, uh,
not only are they drunk,
they also possibly just interested
because they just came to see comedy with
quotes around it and they didn't, uh,
you know, bother to research like,
like Bachelorette parties. You still have
one of those from time to time. Right.
Because the comedy clubs,
they booked that date.
They didn't book it because
you are going to be there.
That's the night of their
Bachelorette party, you know,
and then they go and they
do what they always do,
which has ruined it for every table around
them. Yeah. We had a bad one in Austin.
I remember we had those girls kicked out
and the one girl said she was gonna Sue.
Why did they even have hubs allowed?
UBERKITTENS cause they want to make some
money, do what they do like the money.
But I do think that that would be cool
if a comedy clubs stepped up and said,
you know what?
No bachelorette parties and a group
of six women want to come down.
I refuse to believe that.
All bachelorettes or cons I refuse.
I know a lot of good.
I've had some good ones and I always
congratulate them because it's a,
it's amazing when they're good.
I as soon as I see a Bachelorette party
in the audience, I'm like, oh there's,
there's the lady in the Dildo hat that's
had too much to drink and then I'm
going to have to deal with her the
whole show. And it's, you know,
cause they want it to be about them.
They don't want, they're not there to,
they're not there to share. And a comedian
with the rest of the audience, right.
They're there to have
a private performance.
They should just hire us to
come and call them a bunch
of, you know, you stupid see words
and then they laugh and give us money.
This is the thing that some women have,
and I want to say women,
but dumb checks have, you know,
I know it's not you girls,
but there's some of them have where
if it's their birthday or if it's an
anniversary or if it's
their bachelorette party,
they feel like they are as to number
one really it's my birthday or like,
whoa, reach when it's my birthday.
Don't you get that constantly,
but that's a good, but that's on
Twitter. That's not annoying to me,
but at a comedy club, how many clubs do
it more than dudes? It was a video of one.
The girl,
we got a video of this girl,
she was heckling and then afterwards
we're back at the back of the comedy club
and a, I go, you know,
oh, you're such a jerk. You're such a
jerk. And I go, you wouldn't shut up.
And they'll go, hey, it's her
birthday. It's her birthday. I go,
you're yelling in the middle of a common.
Then she called me fat. I pulled my shirt
up. I'm like, bitch was called Joe Rogan.
Fatso. Yeah, she called me fat and I'm
like, why? Where are you getting fat?
Cause I wear baggy clothes,
you know,
a lot of times on stage and aware like
a baggy sweatshirt and I guess she
thought I was covering something
so I had a show where the slabs,
I get that same shit all
the time. Yeah, I know man.
It was a pretty good judge though.
As far as like own edge videos.
It's like 14 seconds of shut the
fuck up and it's like so quick.
It's like a you,
you know why
you guys stop. Oh it's your birthday.
You're such a jerk. It's her birthday.
I'm like, listen, I'm just a comedian.
You guys wouldn't shut the fuck up
fat. You're fat. Like puffer
cheeks out at me. Like wow, rude.
If I was fat with differences that make
it fun, fat, you're still a cunt. It ever,
everyone I've met,
every single person I've met who said
you were mean to me during a show one day
I say, were you drunk? And then
Diego. Yeah. And then I go,
do you remember anything
that either of US said? No.
They just walk away with this impression
that you're the asshole because they
ruined the show and you had him thrown
out or you or you, you know, put,
put them in their place.
Do you recognize the obligation that you
have to be a little more nice than the
average person because you're famous
when someone meets you that they're going
to be a little weirded out by it all
and so you have to give them some slack.
Yeah,
I know.
That's why I'm always kind of offended
or surprised when people have a different
perception. Like a guy recently
wrote on Twitter, you know,
I just got to tell you or was a girl,
but she was like,
it was going to tell you you were kind
of a Douche when we met you after your
show and and wherever Dallas or whatever.
And it's just like right back and forth
a little bit and you start to get the,
oh no, no, they did. You know, they, they
three back down immediately. They don't,
they don't really mean like douche sounds
harsher to me than they probably meant
it to be. You know, I've, I've met people
before and not even famous people before,
but I met people when I was younger and
for whatever reason I chose to not like
them.
You know,
like your pick something like something
he said something and you blow it out of
proportion, you make a fucking big deal
out of it. And then it, because you know,
it's like, it's almost like a natural
thing to do when the person's not there,
you know, if you're weak, you
know, I had an instance on a,
at this website that go
to mixed martial arts.com
where I met a guy in an elevator.
Okay.
And I didn't even meet him
in the elevator. We were all
in the elevator together.
No one said anything.
And apparently on the way out he said
hello where he said something and he
doesn't,
doesn't think that I responded.
So he went online and wrote this whole
long thing rogue me being a churchy.
Sure wanna be and he's
twice as big as me and fuck,
he was rude to me.
They'd go right into everything
they supposedly hate about you,
but they know it all because they
had liked all those things about you.
Like they are a fan and then they just
suddenly, no, this wasn't even realistic.
This, he suddenly turned on
you though the turns so fast.
Well this wasn't even a turn.
I mean this, this was a,
just an undoubtedly a guy with issues
undoubtedly of guy with, you know,
he's on a mixed martial arts website.
A lot of those guys have anger issues.
You know, like I have in my past,
I've had a lot of anger issues.
I understand it and you know, it's his
interaction with someone who's, you know,
famous and all of a sudden,
you know,
he's comparing himself to me and
he's a bigger person than me.
So he's got that over me and then he
feels like he said something to me and I
didn't respond. So it was like fall
camp. So the rest of it was fuck him.
And then he gets online and writes this
whole thing and I said, listen man,
I don't know what happened,
but if I saw you,
I guarantee you I'm one of the nicest
people you'll ever meet. I saw,
I just turned, my grandmother died and
I was standing in an elevator. Right?
It could be anybody. It could be
anything like it. Also just that,
that'd be that crazy to think just because
they're saying it as they leave the
elevator, that that a of response
absolutely must be forthcoming
or something. People want you
to be a cunt. They really do.
They root for you to suck because if
you're not happy that with the way your
life is going and you meet
somebody that you feel envious of,
where you feel like,
you know,
why is this person in the public eye
and I'm not being the public eyes,
a weird fucking thing. And if you're a
guy, a lot of guys wish they were famous,
like 99% wish they were something of
significance. Even if they're not,
you know, even if it's not
famous, they want to be wealthy.
They want to be a a man that you admire.
They want to be someone in
a high position. It's just
normal chimpanzee shit.
So when you meet some guy and you're
like, who the fuck is this? Doug Benson,
we with you? He's not
fucking cool to me. What?
I fucking buy your CD fucking shithead.
And you're like,
I didn't know you said Hi. Sorry I
was on the phone. They just don't,
they open with that stuff. Yeah.
They just walk right out. Oh yeah,
they're looking at you. Yeah.
I guess you're a hot shot, Huh?
Everybody over there has been saying that
you in some sort of movie or something.
Why do you think you're so special?
It's amazing.
You know what dude say to me all the time,
I thought you were taller all the time
and they want to hang out and be friendly.
We want to see if I thought
you were taller and it's,
it's not like there's no sense of,
you know, like social awareness.
There's no second. Yeah, I
know. They're totally like,
I'll be more interesting
than somebody else,
but can go take a ruler mark out
five foot eight on your wall.
If you see me, expect me to be
there. That's how tall I am.
I've been this tall for 43 fucking years.
That's fine. People can plan for it.
Let's get mean. Do you go up to blind
people and fucking give him the finger?
Like what do you do? What are you doing
man, you you getting is a great idea.
They wouldn't even talk a
lot of shit around the deaf,
but they would hear the whisper of your
front hand over my mouth and through the
year. What if they grabbed your wrist
and some Steven Seagal constantly.
Likewise your finger in front of my face,
mother fucker.
You get your finger in front
of my face because I'm blind.
There's a, there's a new blind
guy that's at my Starbucks.
I go to Starbucks everyday so I see the
same people every day kind of thing.
And there's a new guy just recently became
blind and I feel bad for him because
he's a little older guy
and stuff like that,
but he's the worst blind
person ever because he says
pretty much groping people.
He's like running into people like
he has the one that sticks and he's a
slapping little kids over is sit there
in line and everyone's just like in shock
ready to just like grab him.
Maybe his hearing's not good. And
you know like, uh, like the blind,
they say that your hearing gets much
better and you tuned into your senses.
But if he became blind as he got older,
yeah, maybe he's hearing is already bad.
And then he goes blind.
Well, I mean there's people like
rearranging Starbucks just so he can walk.
How does Aldon all to feel about them?
Any,
any issues or weird by the way that I
think about it for people don't know what
we're talking about.
Brian was stones and he ran into Alan
Alda and he was pretty sure Alan Alda was
mad dogging them. See, it's
basically what we just talked about.
It's like you did it with Alan Alda.
Be like,
fuck out all that he got on the podcast
and double finger. Don't Fuck Allen.
That does look concern.
Like he somehow knew that three 15 year
olds just showed me they're buttholes.
Yeah. That was on you though
too. Some girls flashed him.
Some little school girls thought it was
cute to Flash Brian and it was buttholes
and vaginas. There was, everyone
was end vaginas. The whole package.
The whole package.
Well,
it's good because if it wasn't just a
butthole and nothing else and you'd be
like, what the fuck are you
trying to, is this a cry for help?
Is this a flesh colored SOS?
Heine I'll tell you something about
Alan Alda though. I hope. Please do it.
Doesn't do autographs.
Doesn't really, yeah, so that,
say anybody that meets him could
walk away going, what a Dick.
Because he just says,
I'd rather just shake your
hand or whatever and I'd
rather shake someone's hand
to, but if they want me to
write something down I'll,
I'll be happy too because
then they can remember it.
They look at it and they remember it.
It's just the only problem with autographs
and shit like that and photos like
especially the only time I really
ever an issue with it is that the UFC,
because sometimes I just can't do it.
Like when I'm working,
you know you've been in the UFC cage side,
I'm supposed to stay cage side and
these people was like, come over,
take a picture of like the fights
are going to start in one minute.
I can't just one. I can't do just
one because you look behind you,
there's a thousand people.
I can't just take one and you know
sometimes like you got to go to press
conferences and there you have to run
through these people like I'm sorry I have
to go.
That's the only time.
But other times I see people and
making them happy to sign your shit.
I'll pass on people.
When I was a little kid,
ace freely signed a piece of paper for me,
man,
and I washed it accidentally
like a retard, but I,
it was so faint I could still see it.
So I went over it with a sharpie.
I went over the very careful cause I
wasn't an artist very carefully with a
sharpie and then my aunt I, you know, she
goes, did you go over it with a marker?
And I said, yeah, and you
know what she said? She goes,
it's not going to be worth as
much now. I'm like, what a,
can't put a negative comment.
My mom sold my Bob hope autograph
and a garage sale for 5 cents.
She sold it to at five
sentence when I met Bob Hope,
I also met Sean Connery at that
person made like, you know,
10 or 15 more cents on it.
Why would you sell your autographed
copy of Bob Hope's autograph?
She just took all my books and she's like,
I'm just getting rid of it.
And I had a book that had a Sean
Connery and Bob Hope's autograph on it.
It was a like a guide
to this golf tournament,
like one of those program
guides or whatever.
And they were assigned both of it and
they were really cool autographs and she
sold it like a whole box of books for
Torrey Pines, that tournament? No,
it's called the memorial tournament in
Columbus, Ohio. It's like once a year.
It's like Jack Nicklaus and
started it and it's pretty big one.
It's all the celebrities used to always
go there and kind of a weak move by your
mother. I went to one down south.
Where are they? They did it every year.
I'd go with my dad and I get pictures of
the weirdest celebrities and of course
Bob hope was there,
so I got to have a picture of like I
hate stood in front of is a golf cart.
Oh really? Yeah. And uh, they had to
kind of yell at me, get out of the way,
but I got the shot. I was like,
yeah, I was eating very, a young pup.
Razzi he signed my
autograph it with anything.
There was a big crowd and
he just went right to me.
He didn't sign anyone else's autografting
got [inaudible] you got kid guy.
OCD is fun on Twitter. Reminded me that
the chicken Austin who was heckling,
who was the Bachelorette was screaming.
Sarah Pailin is my aunt.
She was telling me that Sarah Palin
was her aunt. Like she has some power.
Do you say normally or what is she
saying? God, I say aunt [inaudible].
I say aunt cause it was so funny.
You don't say Aston Fundraising Austin
to yell on cause it sounds so proper.
Right? Wait, wait. Yeah.
I say Anna Nerissa heard aunt.
There's a u in there bro on now.
But my friend Dmitri said it best because
I was trying to figure out what is
right, what is wrong and he
said there's a u in there.
That's why I say [inaudible]. I'm
like God damn it. You're right.
And we gave knuckles to each
other. We both agreed on is. It is.
So you also go with often over often?
No, I think I said it was a t in there.
I say often I allow science, silent
t's. I don't allow silent use.
Those sound used can go fuck themselves.
That's what I say.
You got your own set of rules. My
rules, we already have an answer. Okay.
We've got plenty of yours to need more
confused than the English language.
Apparently the English language is a
motherfucker if you come from another
language,
but man,
you know what to me is a motherfucker's
any Asian language where they have
characters. It's supposed to be good
for you to learn other languages.
You know it's supposed to be a
conversation. If you're young,
I'm this close to pulling the trigger on
just getting a Rosetta stone for some,
you know,
Spanish or something and download it.
Really trying to learn another one. I love
the Latino culture. I would love to do,
if I had enough Spanish to do a Latino
comedy shows, I think that'd be cool.
I would love to do that. I'd love to do
some Chels Latino shows with Joey Diaz,
but I would have to open shitty Spanish.
Let's seriously Joe it.
Let's learn Spanish and then do some
shows. How long would it take for us?
I Dunno. My Buddy learned Portuguese
and Rosetta stone and like a few months.
Really? Did he get Brazil or Portugal?
Uh, Brazil. Wow, that's awesome.
They have a different flavor of a
Portuguese cause I've heard people speak
Portuguese and Brazilian sounds so
much cooler, like catch Italian,
such a wild country. Brazilians are mad
at me. There's a few that don't get it.
They're upset at my toxoplasma
comments. I love Brazil. I'm a,
I'm a brown belt in Brazilian Jiu Jitsu.
I've been studying it since 1996 I
have a ton of Brazilian friends chew.
Hoss Korea's from those. The fogo de
Chao. That's my favorite. All time food.
And you're going to be there. It's
29th. I might not. I might be giving my,
I might be getting my tonsils removed my
titles and my adenoids. Yeah. I, you know,
I have sleep apnea.
I have to sleep with a mouth piece and
I've just broke it the other day when I
was in Toronto and had a glue this
fucking thing together with Krazy glue.
And Kevin Booth, uh, the guy
was bill Hicks, producer.
He produced my first DVD that we filmed
in Austin and he just got the operation
time and he told me it's awesome and
he can breathe so much better now.
And I have, I have a fat neck
man. I have a big tongue.
And what they do is when my,
when I go to sleep,
my tongue like closes over my air
hole and it, you know, you, you,
you choke and you gag. So I have this
mouthpiece. It keeps my tongue in place.
But if the mouthpiece breaks, I'm
fucked. And then I don't sleep right.
And then I wake up a bunch of times
in the middle of the night because I'm
coughing. It's like 34 times an
hour. My sleep gets interrupted by,
by choking and gagging.
It's like some pretty serious shit.
It's like every two minutes I'm choking.
So, um, I have to do something about it.
And this is a, that's a good stretch
of time. So if I have that operation,
I probably won't be in Brazil.
But the point is all these Brazilian
people got mad at me the other day on
Twitter. They were like,
Yo, you're talking all these
sheets about Brazil. You know,
because I said the toxoplasma
makes is 66% of Brazil's infected.
It might be as high as 80% of that belief
and that it makes men aggressive and
then it doesn't have the same effect
on women and in fact makes it more
submissive.
And the,
they've actually found a
direct correlation between
successful soccer teams and
toxoplasma infesting
infections because this,
this parasite actually makes people
aggressive and make people reckless.
And that's why I said it's like mean
think when you think about Brazil,
you think about these wild motherfuckers
and you think about these beautiful
women.
And I'm like,
how crazy is it that 60% of this
country is infected more by this,
this toxo plasma?
And then you find out that there's other
strains of this shit and that it's not
just, it's also, by the way, 60 million
Americans are infected by this shit too.
So I'm not like shitting on Brazil
when I'm talking about is some weird,
it's like thinking about nationalism at
this point is the most ridiculous thing
to do because what you should be thinking
about is that there's a brain parasite,
a parasite that affects the
way your fucking brain works.
In 66% of Brazil's infected by
80% of France is infected by it.
60 million Americans. And
these people are like, Oh,
you've tooken all this shits about Brazil.
And I don't know if it's
a translation issue.
I don't know if they just have it and
they're pissed. They're screaming at you.
Could be that. It could hurt,
effected. It could be that.
But I think it's a nationalism thing too.
I think if they don't understand
the language very well,
they can get confused and think
that I'm talking shit on Brazil.
So the last thing we'll do, why would
I do that? So fucking awesome country.
It's a wild country. It's the country
of one of my favorite things to do.
Brazilian Jujitsu. If it wasn't for the
Brazilians, man wasn't for the one family,
that Gracie family and all
of the off shoots. You know,
everyone who learned under that, my
ada dude, everyone who learns Jujitsu.
What a fascinating group of human beings.
They literally changed martial arts.
You know,
I did martial arts my whole life dude.
And up until 1993 no one had
any idea what Jujitsu was.
No one had an,
there was a few people that knew
like a few gene labelle's out there.
And guys who knew about judo.
I knew wrestlers,
you could take it down and you know,
I'd heard a choke holds and stuff before,
but there was nothing
like as comprehensive as
Brazilian Jujitsu as you know,
exhibited by hoists. Gracie, when
you first entered into the octagon,
that fucking blew everybody's mind.
And it's one bad ass family from Brazil.
Ilial Gracie, the old man of, of
Brazil. It was such a bad motherfucker.
He had like 16 sons or something crazy.
And they're all killers. They're all,
he like made an army of, of black
belt killers. Every one of his sons.
Holys Helson uh, all of
them fucking Hickson. The,
all of his sons were these bad ass
savages that could strangle you. I mean,
it's amazing.
They're cousins Carlson.
It's like there's all these fucking other
people in, in, in, in involved in the,
in the family tree. Everybody connected.
Like what a weird, a weird place.
What an amazing thing that something is.
[inaudible] this one guy and his family
gave birth to this revolution in martial
arts. Like fuck all the other
martial artists throughout history.
No one's ever had the kind of
contribution that this one families had.
The Gracie family has done something
like when you talk about like the,
the biggest contributors to martial arts,
there's no one who's even close to them.
No one comes close.
There's people who have helped and karate
and it's more time masters and there's
people perfected boxing. There's great
wrestlers, there's all these great.
But as far as like one influential family,
no one can fuck with the Gracies.
It's amazing.
Have you been tinkering?
The lady called you fat and you
just met your neck. Yeah. Have you,
have you been tested for toxic
plastic? Me. Just for fun. Just to,
maybe you've been hanging out with
all these Brazilians and stuff.
Maybe they sneeze like you get it that
way, bro. I'll get it from cats. The cats.
Maybe they had cat feral cats. You have
to be very careful with feral cats.
A lot of feral cats have
it and uh, it's uh, it's,
they get it from killing
rats and the way it works.
I've talked about this before
on the podcast. So in, in
the interest of brevity,
just look up toxo plasma on Google.
The short version is it's a parasite that
affects rats and it makes them lose it.
They lose their fear of cats and it makes
them horny for the smell of cat piss.
It rewires their bra. They go
near the cat, the cat them.
Then the cat gets this toxoplasma cat
shits in the grass. Animals get it.
You eat the animal, you get it,
you touch the cat shit, you get it.
You know the cat feces.
Somehow like cat cats lay their dirty
asses on your kitchen table or they clean
themselves. And if you drop a cookie
on that and then you eat that cookie,
you could easily get some
cat feces and your food.
You'd be amazed if you have
cats where you have cat feces,
you probably have it all
on your phones everywhere.
They scraped the cat
litter box and they didn't.
They'd lay in there around
and then they walk around.
He sees went right in my mouth the second
I walked in there. Dirty little cons.
But you know, the bottom line is,
the real concern is feral cats.
If you have cats that don't leave your
house, you don't have to worry about it.
But if you have feral cats,
there's videos online of cat of rats
that are infected by Toxo and they run
right up to cats and jump on them. They
don't give a fuck about cats. There's,
or there's a crazy video of a rat.
There's like three cats and it's an
outdoor rat and this rat runs up to these
cats and just starts jumping up in the
air and like snapping at these cats.
He's not scared of him at all.
And the cats are freaking out and
they don't even know to kill him.
They'll look for, they don't such bizarre
behavior. So my friends in Brazil,
I love you relax the Fogo
de Chao talking shit.
I'm not talking shit about Brazil.
I love Brazil.
I got all these fights between fuck you,
Joe Rogan and all this crazy
shit in Portuguese too. I'm like,
please people relax. It's
Americans to 60 million. It's,
you need to be concerned about this
fucking thing and people need to protect
their kids and you need to protect babies
because when babies get it, it's very,
very dangerous. Pregnant
women get it. It's very,
very dangerous when pregnant women,
uh,
that's one of the things that
doctors tell them very specifically.
Do not fuck with litter boxes when you're
pregnant because if you get that toxo
they're just learning about this stuff,
man. Their Geo Xo, toxic plasma May.
Yeah. Toxoplasma Gondii
or Toxo. Plasmosis it's a,
it's some creepy shit, man.
And you know crazy. Yeah.
I never heard about it until a couple
tough years ago. He said, I'll get tested.
Take bets. See. I probably haven't.
You think you have it could have it
have a test for. I've had a wild,
a lot of wild cats. I had a, I had
feral cats in the past. Interesting.
I'm going to have it. I've pretty
reckless. I'm pretty reckless, you know,
I feel stupid shit. I feel pretty angry.
I'm not angry as long as I work out,
but if I don't work out, supposedly,
if your immune system is strong,
it keeps it in check and fights it off
pretty well. My immune system's not bad,
but I should get tested.
They say a disproportionate amount of
motorcycle accident victims test positive
for toxo. Why? They don't know the
doctors are people are reckless.
Yeah, maybe. I guess that's
weird to think about. Yeah.
It's pretty ballsy riding around on
a motorcycle. Yeah. Especially in La.
I understand that a lot more in like
a Texas or in like an open area,
like they can never be too open.
I like, you know, there's just,
cars are not looking for you.
If you want to learn more about this,
this is the number one expert is a guy
named Robert Sapolsky. And His name,
if you spell it,
s a p o.
O. L. S. K. Y. Just look up doctor.
So Polski [inaudible] um, and then, uh,
and look up toxo plasma and you'll,
you'll find it.
Just Google that and he's off every
word about it. Oh No, no, no, no, no.
It's way more connected to schizophrenia.
It's connected to a bunch of
different things. There's a, you know,
there's a lot of instances in the wild
of parasites changing the behavior of
their hosts and causing their host
to even commit suicide. You know,
there's a lot of different things,
like there's a warm that we've talked
about before and aquatic worm that grows
inside of a grasshopper and then once
it reaches the point of gestation,
convinces the grasshopper to jump in
the water and the grasshopper drowns and
then escapes by crawling out of its body.
It just breaks out of its
body like the alien chest.
Burster that's pretty sweet and it's
pretty dope when you think about it.
If nature is to devise some incredible
ways to keep moving on, you know,
and we are the most
incredible, you know, we,
we look to look at all these crazy
parasites like, wow, that's amazing man.
A worm grows in a grasshopper. Fuck
a worm and fucker. Grasshopper.
What about people you know,
were the weirdest thing to
nature's ever created? Man,
we can't even, we have to wear clothes.
We wear some shit that we invent.
We all do with what percentage
of the population, whereas
close,
just so you won't jump on me.
Everybody take a shot.
If you want the Rogan drinking game,
the old Brian shot it's time. Oh
Brian. That's what he's there for.
If you, if you weren't near
him and you saw her a lot,
your body all the time,
you would know.
You wouldn't know where
those comments stem from.
I was glad you grew a beard because I,
your face used to be so kissable
I couldn't, it doesn't look like
you're 36 yeah. When's your birthday?
August 4th then you'd be Leo anymore,
but you should shut up. Yeah,
that shit all around. Didn't they
shift? You know, that's all bullshit.
You just sort of a new gay, that was all
distinction. That was all bullshit. Yeah.
That, that the person that was saying all
that shit was bullshit. Supposedly the,
this, this a straw with money in
astrology if stepped on that guy.
But it's stuff funny. This astrology
thing is bullshit. This one's bullshit.
Those other ones are legit.
I don't believe in astrology.
I definitely believe in being born
and a certain time of the year if I,
if me and you were born in August,
I think that there's a lot of different
little things that are different than
say somebody who's born in November,
you know, just like little things,
like as an example,
when we were growing up our birthdays
that were never announced on this school
message system,
you know,
so we had that little bit of difference
and you can't let it go. Can, you know,
like little things like
that. That's what, that's,
that's Kinda what I believe there is.
I think
man, whenever something
is around for a long time,
I consider it whenever something's around,
whether it's religion, whether it's,
you know,
whether it's some sort of a belief of
the cyclical nature of the universe.
You know,
an age is like you,
you look into like the what
the Mayans believe in it.
And whenever you look into anything
that people believe for a long period of
time, we've got to go, hmm, where's
all this coming from? Where,
what does this astrology thing and
why did you all you people that were
struggling to find food to
eat and fighting off diseases,
why did you all agree on this?
Why did you all get together and decide
that there's 12 Zodiac symbols and each
one of them represents a very distinct
sort of personality and that, you know,
they can't,
you know,
they can't like mingle with each other
and be happy because this one counteracts
that one. And I don't know, I
don't know if it's really, I'm not,
but I know that it gets
all those things started.
Like there's somebody that
everybody listens to maybe,
but it's super complicated.
It's not like when you think
about like the shit that you get,
like when you go to the newspaper and
you look under Leo and you go, Oh,
that's not me, but that doesn't,
that's silly. That's silly.
But apparently if they could find out,
hey,
Brian Ryko was born at 3:00 AM and where
was he born? He was born in Columbus,
Ohio at 3:00 AM on August the fourth and
they can look at that and they can go,
oh, okay. And we'll back then, whatever
the year, what, what year was that?
74 1974 this was happening and this star
was here on this planet was here and
this, I think there's
gotta be something to that.
And it sounds hippy and sounds ridiculous,
but we,
we know that the moon affects the tides.
We know that.
And we know that people are certain,
we thought it was 90% when you're correct,
and it's like 60% water.
So people are 60 something percent water.
We know that there's some sort of
an effect just based on gravity.
And we know that also planets must
affect us. The gravity of, you know, Star
when you were conceived, even, even going
back months to when you're conceived,
the depressure of when you came
into from sperm hitting the egg,
what was the bearer pressure? You know,
is it like know it was at a high pressure?
Maybe that changes though. Cause it's
such a small little thing anyways that,
you know, the, the littlest
thing could change,
right? A lot of pressure. When you
were, I know there's a lot of friends,
were you in Colorado? Were you in
Florida? You know, where were you? Where,
where was it happening?
How racist are you going to be?
How much oxygen did you bring get
when you were born? Did you got wd 40?
Maybe that's one of the reason why
people in Colorado so cool. Maybe just,
just always just a little high because
it's so the altitude, it's really, um,
I gotta be careful whenever I go
there with booze. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You've gotta be careful with booze. Booze
will knock you. Run Your Dick. If you,
I wish you would come to
see that fucking house.
And I had rented up in the mountain.
Man, when you get high up there,
Holy Shit at 8,300 feet above sea
level, when you get high, it's like,
it's, it's a different sort of experience.
It's like, it's like eating pot,
you know when you smoke it, it's,
it'd be just like eating it.
It was just like blast right
into yourselves. Really
kind of crazy man, you know?
Cause there's not much oxygen up there.
So for whatever reason the marijuana
hits yarder booze hits your heart.
It's going to hit me really hard on
June 18th and how many works downtown or
Larimer Square?
Lammers squares.
Hard to find because the street's
not on the fucking navigation system.
That's a new one. Yeah. That's when I
realize how connected I am to electronics.
Like they gave me some directions over
the phone. Yeah. Turn right here. I'll go.
Okay. Okay, okay. Or tried to remember it,
but then I just plugged
into my navigation system.
Like what the fuck do
you mean it's not here?
So I had to try to get
something reasonably close.
I hate that.
I hate the shit when it's just something
small to where it's like you didn't
choose Las Angeles and
Beverly Hills or you didn't do
oh spell outdoors little peccadilloes
this little little differences like it's
amazing to me.
Like it's funny to me when you type
in something something.com and you
excellently hit a comma that they haven't
worked that out yet where we just go,
oh you meant to put a period there.
There's no reason to have a comma in a,
in a URL. It doesn't even make sense.
But you just got to work that stuff out.
There's so many,
like I'm sure every time they,
you know like spell check on my
new iPhone is going to have, yeah.
What supposedly iPhone just hired
uh, one of the guys that, fuck,
I can't remember it to do their maps,
they're going to try to,
I think have a driving type
maps on the upcoming iPhone
is the new iPhone is going to be big.
Like the HCC,
I don't believe it's going to be bigger
than the screen might go from corner to
corner. Like there'd be
less real state. You know,
like if you look at the iPhone now,
there's like a big chunk on the top and
bottom, you know that's not screen right.
I believe that probably
that will be stretched out,
but I don't think the phone's
going to be actually bigger.
I don't like those big huge droid
phones where it seems like there's,
there's the Tia 81
calculator in your pocket.
Okay. This is a little big, but God damn,
it's awesome when you're
scrolling through web pages,
your life's not awesome
at all. Triply. Yeah.
Triple who was complaining
about his battery life,
but he's got that HTC evo when
you're online with that thing,
that is the shit first of all.
That four G is fucking dope. Yeah.
God Damn.
It's awesome.
He was pulling up web pages like you're
at home on cable modems. It's amazing.
Like Bang, Bang photos.
Instantly everything.
They measured one of Verizon's new phones,
the thunderbolt or HTCs thunderbolt,
the fucking,
they showed the,
on one of the online websites
where they analyze a cell phones,
they showed the download and upload speed.
It's like fucking cable modems.
It's insane for g is ridiculously fast
and you know what else is cool about
those droids? You can talk text messages.
You press a little thing and you go,
hey Doug,
I'm running 10 minutes late.
I'll call you when I get there
and it's really fucking accurate.
It's really good.
Like I did it with my friends.
The only thing he got wrong was my name.
Here's a few, said, hey, what's up?
This is Joe Rogan and I just want to say
I love you. It got everything like said.
It said Logan instead of Rogan.
There's tons of apps for that though,
for the iPhone and stuff like that for
tweets and stuff like that. Yeah, yeah.
They even have dragon on the iPhone,
but the
right, but does that go
straight into tweets? It's an
option when you, like if you,
if you go for tweets or text messages,
it's an option.
Like you know how like you look at
your thing and you can add a photo or
something like that. You can make
an an MMS, you know what I mean?
With them it's like,
here's the video here.
You can add this and here
you can do it by voice.
Logan Rogan things going to be a great
like misunderstanding in some sort of
Romcom or something. They'll del
La, they'll take advantage of that.
It'd be like a story twist
that somebody who meant to,
you know meant to the voice message one
person and it will be a murder out wrong.
It would fuck Joe Logan and Joe
Logan Credit. He was like, fuck you.
And the guy's like, I don't even know
you. Oh yeah. Well I fucking know you.
I know where you live.
And then shit got crazy.
And really it was just because of me,
bro gains its worst.
That's the worst when you're
losing your hair especially.
And your name is Rogan and the stuff
that cures your hair is like Rogaine.
That's,
that's so rude.
That would have been really rough if you
were losing your hair when you were a
kid. I was with Amy, who's,
who's who is Joe Rogan.
I doubt many people would dare yelled
at at you. What are you talking about?
I hear that every day.
People yelling at you,
they call you. Yeah. Oh yeah. I've
heard it a million times. Wow.
Andy Dick use it on Howard Stern,
the nerve of people.
I dodge that bullet when Andy
Dick fell off the wagon. I said,
he has to be sober for a year
before he can come over my house.
So when he got arrested I was like,
yeah, it's just bought myself some time.
Start the clock again another year.
Andy, as he can never draws them.
I'm so Saba.
He's still welcome at the death squad.
Izzy is welcome at your house
and whether you like it or not,
he knows we live in a strategic move.
I ran into him on the streets a couple
of weeks ago at the Bridgetown comedy
festival and it was, you
know, 6:00 PM or something.
He was just gone and just being a
complete asshole. I was just like,
Margaret Cho was dragging him around is
so crazy. It was. I didn't know that.
He's talked to a ton of shit about
me on I'm mark Marin's podcast.
We're just talking about me.
When we were younger on Newsradio about
what an asshole I was to him. I said,
no idea and that, and then, you know,
he came on the podcast and you barely see
he was, he was, he was intimating that,
you know, I was mean to him when
he was young, but I'm like, dude,
he used to pull your dick out.
He used to show up fucked up.
Couldn't probably just always hate it.
Look on your face like,
what the fuck are you doing? It was
hard work. That's translates into you.
He's a meaning you to see it as a stand
around and laugh at all my antics.
But on Marin's podcast, God, he like had,
it's so twisted. It was so ridiculous.
I don't, that's, I don't think he
should be a witness for anything.
I don't think you should ever get to say,
well, here's what I thought happened.
Are you kidding? I want him writing my
autobiography. This is what I remember.
You're hangry. You so angry
at me. He, I was, uh, in my,
in my trailer with my girlfriend and I go,
what do you Jang janking
they're aging and they're like,
I'm getting dressed Andy up and up to
when I talk to you. So open up the door.
He's got his dick in his hand.
It's not even hard. And he's like,
kind of like pull on us. Are you mad
that it's not hard or would you rather
have some respect? You know, don't be so,
so brave that you could pull your
dick out. It's not even hard yet.
It's just assuming you're
such a bad mother fucker.
You can keep this party going, but that's
what she does do right? Don't flashers.
Just show their flacid Dick.
Do they?
I don't think they work one up
and then open their trench coat.
There's no such thing as flashers anymore.
Did you know that you're all wet
shoes, bro? This plenty of flashes.
I would you talking about Brian?
I know a bunch of girls who've had guys
whipped your dick. Yes, I know a bunch.
I think about doing it all the time.
Comics,
one day I might pull the trigger.
I might go through with this check off.
Doug, did you ever have them on
your show? Who, Andy? Yeah, he did,
uh, just with, we didn't tape
it for anything, but he did
show up on one of my, uh,
interruption shows and it just became
like kind of a serious conversation about,
you know, what he was going through
at that time. You know, he had the,
he had the thing on his ankle and, you
know, part of things trying guy like Andy.
Andy's a very funny man. He's one of
the funniest guys I've ever worked with.
One of the most talented,
like comedic actors I ever worked with.
And I really do love the Guy I, even
though I don't want them over my house,
I really do love,
he's an incredibly gifted,
but in a way it's almost like he's so
gifted from such an early age that like
that can kind of turn somebody into
a Weirdo that they, you know, they,
they can't really relate to people
in an irregular way because there,
I think he had, I told
him, I don't think it's,
that's it at all knowing Andy hit fucking
horrendous childhood. It was beyond,
he can't even remember it,
but it was probably so freeing to run it,
to end up with a, you know, Ben Stiller
and that whole crowd and to be, and to be,
you know,
like how old was he when the Ben Stiller
show was on early twenties right? Yeah.
He must have been, cause he's
pretty young. It's a couple
of years older than me.
I think he's 45 talent.
He had the kind of talent that Dan Akroyd
had in the first few seasons of a SNL
where he was 20 but he could
play a 50 year old and a sketch.
And you don't even question. It was Dan
Akroyd 20 he was super young when the,
the first season of SNL, he must've been
2120 something like that. Dan Akroyd,
he's [inaudible] man because he's a guy
that went from the blues brothers to
some of those fucking movies that he
did were just like, what happened? Did,
did this, you have no control over this
or did you actually think this was funny?
I need to know. I need to know
if you'd liked Caddyshack two.
I need to know there's a lot of three
or whatever the fuck it was. Yeah,
it was two sergeant Bilko, you know, or
any of that crap at either. But you know,
that's the thing is you take
a Steve Martin, you know,
he does some dumb, you know,
bringing down the house kind of stuff.
But he also is writing books
and playing his Banjo and he's,
he's clearly, you know, still a very
talented, if not completely with it,
but somebody like Dan Akroyd,
you just,
you just wonder how did
that talent gets squandered.
Cause he was also great at playing
characters and then he sort of like just
became the Dan Akroyd character and
everything, which was just kind of like a,
you know, goofy pump is fat guy or
whatever. I blamed the House of Blues.
Well that's uh, that's the best thing
he's ever done that in the blues brothers.
Um, but yeah, he's a, he's a
crazy UFO head to yeah. Yeah.
He's super into that stuff.
He's a believer, you know,
a real believer. You know,
Colin had coneheads movies. Not that
bad. No, it's not that bad. Yeah.
Bad is you take like, you think, oh, that
must have been really weak. But it was,
it was actually pretty good. No,
that was decent. It was decent.
But like the blues brothers, like one
of the greatest of all time. Yeah.
I'm to see that again soon.
There's going to be a double bill at
the new Beverly of that and I'm raising
Arizona. Ah, when is this? That's
a Friday night. This Friday night.
Ladies and gentlemen, if you want to
party with Doug Benson and Los Angeles,
where's it at? It's the new
Beverly. The new Beverly,
you should get stuck at seven 30 to nine
30. You should fucking organize mass.
Like Oh, screenings like
organize, say hey everybody,
let's go Friday, April 20, whatever.
It's funny movie theaters just for his
fans and packs it. Who Does Mc? Chris,
how much does it cost to rent out a
whole movie theater? I don't know.
But they do it all the time. So
a lot of money man. Yeah, no,
but I don't need to like $20 seats.
How much does the seat? Well No,
they have deals for renting out a
whole theaters. Really? Yeah. For like,
you know when,
when we used to work at a movie theater,
they used to print them out for like
businesses to show like videos and stuff
like that. I've seen that. Yeah.
I've seen those ads they have,
if you get to the movies too
early before the previews start,
they have like the previous to the
previews and those like show like,
like how you can use it for like
conferences and stuff like that. Yeah,
they got a lot of, uh, a
lot of extra business there.
They always have those, um,
like, you know, come to the theater
to watch a live streaming of an opera
fc. Yeah, we've done a couple of UFC.
UFC does it. What's his name? Did it?
The Fox News Guy.
A Glenn Beck.
He'd do his concerts that way. I
want to talk to him so bad. Huh?
He's one of my all time. All
time. Need to talk to guys.
I would love to talk to him
like in a format like this,
like one of the beautiful things about
the podcast is not just that the podcast
is on iTunes available for free,
but that it's Ustream and it's live.
This is live. This is you. This is
the real Doug Benson. This is no,
but there's no editing. Should really
do some vaporizer hits then. Yeah.
If it's just a real duck show how real.
We talked about some parties,
ladies and gentlemen, the crackling
you hear is plastic right now.
Doctor drew is rolling in his lab coat.
I ran into Dr drew at that
April foolishness thing and
he was with his kids and
I think their fans. Oh,
that's hilarious. Shit.
That's hilarious. You need to find out.
You should have asked a very bluntly,
I'm sorry you fans of mine, I don't
mean to be rude. Do you know who I am?
They seem like they were
pretty receptive to be there.
And then they saw my set
and I at that show I just,
it was wall to wall pot and uh,
Kevin and being said they'd
never seen and you know,
they've been around a lot of musicians
and they said they'd never seen anybody
as high as I was at night.
You were so fucking high in Toronto
and when you came in Toronto we were a,
Doug did a last minute guest that you
were just like go out there and do
something. So I guess bike 10
minutes of the, the, the album,
I just record it.
I couldn't,
I couldn't begin to come up with any new
stuff that you were too big or riff too
much. I, I'm sure I
riffed quite a bit, but I,
I kind of stuck to a plan when
I got out there. I didn't,
I didn't go out there and thinking
like, oh, I'll just go out and
see whatever happens. You
know, there's too many people.
How was I going to do this
bit and this bit, you know,
I wrote it all down right before I went
to hell. Did you really? Yeah. Yeah.
Do you ride a lot?
I mean he's here every day.
Something you do a week on a terrible,
I never sit down to write. I just,
when I think now, especially with
Twitter, if I think of a joke favor,
it's relatively quick.
I just throw it on Twitter.
And if it's more of like a a story
or a, you know, a longer bit,
then I'll just try it the next
time I do a show, you know,
like a lot of my shows now I just start
off with, hey, so here's what I did today.
You know, I just sort of talk
about whatever. And then,
cause then you always know you got the
jokes ready to go when it's time and that
you'll be able to finish strong.
But it's fun to just be able to,
I know I write a lot. I
write a lot of long. Yeah,
you're really intense in that
way and it's a, it's amazing,
especially considering what you're about
to do right now. That's, it's ready.
Jiffy pop is ready. I wonder if it's
possible for the bag to explode.
I've never had that out and it was
never happened. Slowly. Slowly leaks.
You know what, sue sisters, your idea.
So I want you to take the throne.
Fair enough. I think the hardest
part for me is fine. I like,
I'll think of it like a one bit like a
tweet joke that I want to make it into a
whole joke, joke, joke, and
it's hard to take, you know,
just a small little idea
and make it a big joke.
Like I have this thing that happened
actually happened to me the other day.
I think it's Hilarious,
but I need to build off of it.
I can just say that and be
like, ha ha, that's it. You
know? Well, you know what man,
the war of art is a brilliant
book by Dr Steven Pressfield.
Dr Steven Pressfield, I just give them
a doctorate. Hunter, ricks Thompson.
We go in the right way. We're not
going anywhere, bro. It's all good.
We've got plenty of weed. You know what
I'm saying? When people always get like,
no, it's this way. No of
the biggest hassles are man,
the guy who was holding the joint and
wants to start his fucking story. Oh yeah.
Oh my God,
that's the worst.
Or your dog eats or all your
weed or your dog's got an excuse.
He's a fucking dog. The Guy, the
guy who holds the joint is go,
Oh man, you wouldn't
believe this man. Right?
So he's got his joint joint in his hand.
There's a circle like 10 people.
He's like, so I owe the
student loan, right?
I just supposed to take care of it and
like my uncle was supposed to and and
you're like Japan,
that joint,
you fucking jump in right away when I
see that comment because he's holding you
hostage holding on to anymore.
And that's a great thing about what I
love about smoking circle is everyone can
just chat the whole time. You could
be getting high having conversations.
Then it's the only time where you go lip
to lip on something and another man has
it. You don't even flinch. Yeah. Yeah.
Your immune system must be awesome.
Or are you just have the best aids?
All these aides are fighting it out for
battle inside your body. You get tested.
Every aids ever. I had a really good
winter and I didn't even get my,
I usually get a flu shot of
all three types of toxo inside.
You didn't get around to my flu shot
and I didn't and I didn't get sick much
though.
The whole
winter I lucked out. But yeah.
You know what man, this was a,
I had one cold this winter and
it was quick as fuck and I,
I believe it was some sort of a flu and
it was really quick. I go, you know,
I'm like 24 hours sweating and shitting.
As soon as something comes on, you know,
like I just like him just
in the sauna or you know,
or on the floor drinking a lot of fluids.
So you'd believe in sweating and
everything on the toilet. I just, yeah,
just get it.
Same thing with a really bad hangover.
I just want to like get rid of it.
Like I love being hung over like in a
nice hotel in Vegas because they always
have, uh, you know, full blown
steam room. You should go,
you should be careful when
you're sick about working out.
A lot of people used to think that work,
he would sweat it out of you,
but that's not real. And you, when
you, if you have a real workout,
it's one thing is like just gently moving
and slowly kind of breaking a sweat
that's just kind of getting
your circulation going.
But whenever you stress yourself,
like if you like breathing heavy
and you're like really pushing,
you weaken your immune system, super
dehydrated on top of all that. Yes. Yeah,
we usually are. When you have a hangover,
is it crazy? Yeah. You gotta be careful.
I drink a ton of water, that's
for sure. That's the huge one.
The water is the most important thing and
you kind of take fucking vitamins, man.
And most likely you're not getting what
you really need from your food unless
you have a super clean diet. You
need some vitamins. I'm putting out,
I'm with Chris from on it.
Chris Marcus,
we're going to put out this
neuro a formula. Nootropics.
Have you been taking it?
Dude, I've been taken, dude. I've been
taking it do if you've been taking it.
You know what I noticed right away where
the first day I had a really hard time
sleeping.
Yeah.
I was lying in bed and my brain was flying
and my dreams were super vivid and he
told me not to take it before I went
to bed. He told me to take it uh,
earlier and I took it to
like two in the afternoon,
but I was still jazz that in my mind
and one in one in the morning. Yeah.
Have you noticed that? I,
yeah, I've been staying up.
I'm always staying up like that.
So yeah, you're like, well,
you have this crazy tweeting in the
middle of this really loose schedule that
most people would really kill for.
Most people hear about you
on Twitter just like, God.
So loves to just be able to sleep.
Everybody that calls me in the morning or
rights to me in the morning, it's like,
sorry I know you, you know you're
probably not up. And I'm just like,
well you don't really
know me then because I um,
I get up early all the time
because you got to catch a flight,
you got to do vulner getting to
do an interview, you get whatever.
Like I have to get up early
so often they're like,
I've totally become a morning person.
You know,
I have a hard time doing interviews
in the morning. My brain just don't,
doesn't fire that good.
Like when I get up and I go somewhere
and then like you get in the car and then
you get to the radio station,
then I'm woken up.
But like when I just wake up and then
like the first words that I say are on the
air, you have to get on the phone right
away. Oh God. I feel like such a retard.
I like struggle to talk, you know,
but that works for me. So, you know,
like they,
they,
it gets laughs if I'm having trouble
trouble expressing myself, you know,
and they, cause that's the morning
radios. The worst there was like,
oh stoner I had to get up at 7:55
AM to talk to us and it's just like
went for a while preparing for all
these crazy sound effects. Yeah.
That's the only thing that bugs me about
Adam Carolla's podcast. Adam, I love you.
Stop. So I actually listened
to it with those fucking size.
I said listen to it the other day cause
I asked Adam Carolla's podcast cause I
haven't really,
I just don't have time to listen to
other people's podcasts right now.
But I listened to it and uh, he
uh, it was so retarded though.
Sound effects were really bad
times. They make me laugh. Yeah.
It's like in the middle of like Adam
is talking and then middle of it,
then they have like a quote from a movie
that didn't like, it was like what did,
sometimes that is in the middle. It's
definitely an art form. You know,
it's hard to just,
you know,
to have this whole,
all these sound effects loaded in and
pick one really fast. It's appropriate.
But when they nail it,
like I think they,
they're pretty funny out with Howard
Stern sometimes too. He, they're pretty,
they don't do them a lot, but they
do them. Yeah. When they do them,
it makes me laugh sometimes
just cause it's so oftentimes,
it's just so odd to suddenly hear
like, will Farrell, you know,
these welfare all loud on a Corolla
and him just yelling random things.
It's pretty funny.
You know what they have in house or in
this morning I was listening to my car,
they had a fake Arnold and it talking
about the, uh, the divorce. Oh yeah.
Oh my God. It was fucking good. It was
so good. It was so good that I thought,
Holy Shit, Arnold Schwarzenegger is going
off. Like maybe I thought it was real.
I really thought it was real.
It took me like 15 seconds.
Then I take her whole dresses and like
throw them on the bed and I shit all over
them. That's what I was like, okay.
He wouldn't say that. You know,
it was like only me and my underwear.
I get the stories I can't do.
My lead guy calls him, they call him
fake card on whatever your dresses and
um, yeah. He called him afterwards.
He called them fake Arnold.
So while it was going on, man, it's
like the fake David Letterman got, damn,
that guy's good. That holy
Shit. That guy's good.
This fake Arnold is just as good man.
He's fucking dead on. He's dead on.
It's perfect. He's the fucking, you know,
they asked him if he's ever going to get
married again. Fuck you. Never again.
Arnold's getting divorced. He's
like almost dead. It's almost dead.
He's getting divorced.
There's something much more sad about
an old dude that gets divorced if like
Ryan Reynolds got divorced and he like,
who could blame the kid?
He's got perfect bone structure.
You're hung in there.
As long as he could go get
that pussy, go get it, Ryan.
You know what the fuck the guys probably
got a million chicks clawing at them 24
hours a day everywhere he goes. Just
trying to peek at his abs, you know,
God bless him for hanging in there.
Even when scarlet Johannson for a
year and a half. You know what I mean?
You can't fault him. But when you hear
Arnold and Arnold getting divorced now,
he still has checks after no nothing,
nothing.
Just as squats and and beets and extra.
It does become about the
thing different from him.
Like I'm sure he'll get like a lot of
pretty girls that just want attention from
him and Nardo and the last thing they'd
want to do is he'll get stingily sleep
with them.
Broken bitches.
He's going to get some girls who
want to have some sort of a slice of,
he's going to get the kind
of chicks Gary Coleman
was getting. No, you're going to give me
the way Gary Coleman, we're getting chicks
Coleman and his whole act was to, Jasper
had borrowed still a bad bar is still,
you know, he'll get some times
he very quietly made wiggle,
wiggle ISED we will. Why legalized
it? I'm not hating on him. I love him.
I'm just saying, I mean, dude,
Conan the barbarian was one of my all
time fucking favorite movies and the would
not have been the same.
They've got a new Conan coming
out and the dude looks normal,
maybe very charming about most
sports nigger movies because he,
so he just didn't try to, you know,
get an American accent, you know,
he just is who he is, what his name is.
He is like kindergarten cop is hilarious.
His name is Swardson nigger.
You know what I mean?
He's an all time great movie star and
his name is just for the most people
totally on on PR spillable who
the fuck knows how to spell that?
S. C. H. W. A. R. C. E.
This new guy, g. E. R.
This new guy's probably closer to what
Conan really would look like if it was a
guy who was the a sward
around in real life.
He wouldn't be built like
Arnold Schwarzenegger.
He would be built like an athlete who
may want to see Thor. I taught already.
It's awesome. You loved it.
Fuck yeah, it was great.
I have trouble with all the stuff in
the home planet and I just couldn't,
I couldn't let go and just enjoy it.
I just want,
I just wanted to see him get his hammer
and started fighting with people on
earth and wasn't it funny when the guy,
when the guy from the government was like,
uh,
when they see that when you
see the big robot, he's like,
is that one of Tony Stark's robots?
Which is a cute line.
Why isn't the next thing he does is get
on his cell phone and get one of Tony
Stark's to robots to come take care
of this giant robot that's clearly,
clearly means to hurt people. Yeah.
They bring him in. Yeah. What the fuck?
Where's iron man when you need them?
Yeah.
Cause hell if that's what this is is
it's just another setting up an Avengers
movie where they're all going to
be in it, but it's, it's, you know,
it was a cute reference,
but it's also like what,
that's also a solution to your problem.
Yeah, exactly. He's get Tony Stark.
It's like that Old Lord of the rings
thing where they're on an AI dragon at the
beginning of the,
like the first movie like that drag him,
took him somewhere or whatever.
Yeah. And then it's like,
why don't you just ride the
dragon to get the ring, you know,
why'd you have like
all these other things?
He's just,
I just completely checked out on all
the Lord of the rings movies because I'm
just such, not a, I'm not a
fan of any of the mythologies,
so I just was just like watching it just
for the pure spectacle of it each time
and like I couldn't,
I could barely tell you about anything
that happened in those movies.
My Dad and my Stepdad was a hippie and a,
he loved all the Rro token jr tokens.
I read a bunch of them when growing up.
I read that stuff when I was little
and I just never, it's, it's, you know,
like Mike to Genre that can work,
but it's like my least favorite.
Like I'm not excited about this
game of Thrones thing on Hbo.
I've tried watching it and it's, what
is it about? It's just, you know,
that kind of the middle
earth, you know, uh,
did they have dragons
fighting fantasy thing?
They have dragons in the game of
Thrones. Thanks. So yeah, really,
I certainly talk about him. They talk
about genetics, a lot of talk and there,
you know, and it's got sex in it cause
it's HBO and, and you know, but I just,
I always end up like every episode,
I haven't gotten through the whole thing
without checking my Twitter or you know,
doing something else while it's on, you
know, whatever I think about sex and old,
any, anything Victorian era and you just
got to know how bad those fucking people
must have smelled back then. Got The
worst, the worst, their ass hole.
And then they don't like have more sour
expressions on their face all the time.
Like,
oh my God,
it's so [inaudible] smells like urine
this everywhere in this castle using
capitals like an asshole. You think
that people were like dogs back then?
It didn't bother them. Oh, maybe
they just get used to it. Yeah.
I mean maybe there's something thinking,
well you know you get used to smells.
That's the weird thing about smells
like a new sound like or sound rather.
You can have like, they'll stay that
way forever, it'll drive you crazy,
but if there's a shitty smell you're,
you're all factory sensors are only set
up to detect changes in smell so you can
get used to some sulfury nasty smelling
neighborhood. You can get news.
That's why when you drive through New
Jersey and there's some areas in New
Jersey where it's fucking
so badly polluted by plants,
by whatever chemical plants they
have there so badly polluted,
the air fucking stinks. I know for males,
I don't know if it's that way anymore,
but I remember when we were kids
and I was, I lived in Newark.
We would drive through certain
areas and it fucking stunk.
Whenever it drove up the up the
coast here through Santa Maria,
it always, is that a cow area? It might,
it's either a cow area or I people used
to always say paper mill because it
would smell Smith's smell like,
like you know, really bad farts.
How bad is that for those poor
fucks that have to work there?
I guess they do get used to it,
but maybe it's chemicals. Right.
Have you ever been like eating a tuna
tuna canning place or something like that?
No, that's the smell is insane. I had
to hang out on one day when I was uh,
standing in a for a movie.
Uh,
they shot a scene in a real like fucking
tuna cannery down in Long Beach and is
supposed to be a period piece and the
place still looked like hell, you know,
so it still looked like it was all
dose Gary and a man that, that, that,
that place smelled so bad and just
hundreds of workers is that they're just,
you know, putting their hands in
it and smelling it all day long.
We've been to an Asian grocery store.
There's one out here in Northridge
that I went to recently.
And it cause you probably seek out Asian
grocery stores so you could tell this
story. No, I mean like have you ever
been into an Asian grocery store?
Like you went in for cigarettes
or something? No, I just
went in to get candy and
Japanese make great candy,
but you walk in and it smells like
fucking ass, just death of fish.
It smells just like the grow.
And they have like coolers,
like on the ground of just live crabs
and it's like crabs a dollar each and
they're just like huge buckets of crabs.
And then you go and there's like,
you could buy like octopuses
squids and they eat a lot
of freaky shit.
Yeah.
And there's just tons of fish completely
like with their heads on and stuff like
still alive, just in Saran wrap type
thing. And they're still moving a little.
You're just like, this is fucked
up the creek. Where is this place?
I got to check on receipt die in
Northridge. We did fear factor in a,
um, a slaughterhouse and
that was pretty dark man.
It was dark and smelled fucked up. It
smelled. It's, it's like, uh, like, uh,
a displeasure bill smell like you wanted
to get away. And it was a clean place.
They did a great, you know,
I mean it was very cool.
They even killed cows in a kosher
way. There, there was uh, you know,
they would slice her neck.
There was of two different ways they
would do them and one time they were doing
when a rabbi was there and they
would do it, would they have to,
you have to do it with a sharp
knife and slice the neck.
And so we had the weird stench to
it and we had a guy go crazy there.
It was one of the few times on fear
factor was worried about my safety because
this stunt was a guy had a dunk his head,
everybody had a dunk their head in blood.
We had this cow's blood and you had
to keep the cow's blood at 38 degrees.
It couldn't get any warmer
than that because around 40,
41 degrees he starts developing bacteria
like very quickly and you can get
incredibly ill.
So in order to do this,
we had to fill these vats up with
really fucking cold cow's blood.
And this guy was like one of those
Tony Robbins motivational guys.
Like he had bought like motivational
tapes and he had read books.
And he was like repeating his mantra
to him and he was standing outside.
He was a big guy, man. He was like
a football player. He was yoked.
It was a lot bigger than me, man. And
he was standing in front of this, um,
like a side view mirror on a pickup
truck and he was talking to the mirror.
He was like, you are a winner.
You are a person who succeeds.
You are a person who sets
goals and accomplishing them.
And he was pacing back and forth and then
he would go back to that mirror and it
would say it over and over again. And he
was like all this positive affirmations.
And then I was like, oh my God, this guy
is crazy. And I just started taking off.
Fuck, this guy is crazy. We've
got a crazy guy in the show.
How do you screen this
crazy guy on the show?
And so then he gets to the time
where he has to do is stunt well,
there's a bunch of people before
him and they do it and girls do it.
All these people do it, but
he does it. And he starts
freaking out. He can't do it.
He can't. He's choking, he's choking.
You know the reason why it needs
all this crazy motivational shit.
He's got a fucking tornado of bullshit
and his brain and it just wins every time
something comes up and he just can't,
he can't accomplish things.
So he's in this fucking blood and he
starts swapping the blood dot fuck,
fuck. And he's screaming
and he's covered in blood.
And then I'm looking around
and these camera man,
and they all like smoke cigarettes.
They're out of shape. And you know,
there's like a little skinny guy.
I was holding their core and I'm like,
there's no security here.
We've got a crazy guy covered in blood
and I'm going to tell him that he's
eliminated from the show. You just
took care of me to the prom. Exactly.
Ready for fucking lightning
bolts to come out of his eyes,
the place to go on fire. And we all
die in a Stephen King movie. I'd still,
we're always think about the one episode
where they blended the rat in the,
in the blender and they had
to drink liquid rat time
magazine's 10 gross moments
of reality television and we made it.
Yes.
Can you imagine doing that rat
hair mixed with the melted phones?
It's the only thing I
don't like about reality.
Television is the gross out factor
is the best part. I'm a little crazy.
And what's the best part? So I think
the only thing worthwhile season,
it wasn't for fear factor was the first
time it wasn't for the beast. Yeah.
I have obviously a very different take
on it than the average person because
I've been through so much. I've seen
so much. I've seen more gross shit.
Any hundred people go, it's amazing what
wife threw up in her car. Just fuck.
She ate,
she worked out and she'd drink wheat
grass juice and she fucking puked all over
our car, all over the console,
over the seats, everything.
And she was so grossed out by it and she's
like, she's, she can't smell throw up.
If she sells, smells throw
up, she'll throw up again.
I'm like, I'll clean it up.
To me it was nothing. I'm
like, I see so much puke.
I was cleaning it up when I was a kid.
I remember when you were a kid,
you'd walk down the hallway and some
kid threw up and everybody below you'd
smell the throw up and
you'd have to throw up.
I could get right in and
poke around in it like,
like Molly and sculpture or whatever
those Scully and Mulder with a,
with a pencil. I go look at that. There's
a sausage. That's a hot dog. You would be.
So you're completely unaffected
by the pie scene and um,
stand by while I was young back then.
You know what I mean?
That is so disgusting.
I did once watching fear
factor on television.
I never threw up when I was actually
there live when shit was going down.
But there was a girl that was eating a
cocktail glass full of worms and she was
having the hardest time eating it. And I
was telling her that she wasn't a flies.
No,
it was worms.
And she would hit a mouth hole warms and
she's chewing and she throws him up on
this dirty picnic table. Okay.
And I said, you can still win it.
You can still do it. You just got
to put them back in your mouth,
put it back into Mt Mouth.
So she's,
she's so grossed out by these worms that
she can't even pick them up with her
hands and put them in the glass.
She's trying to pick them up with
two glasses at the same time,
and she's slobbering and snots coming out
of her nose and she's crying and she's
shaking and she's getting
these two glasses together
and like, you can do this,
you can do this.
You get it.
She gets it back in her mouth and she
chucks it up again. I go, come on,
you've got plenty of time.
Scoop that back up.
And she did when she threw up the third
time when I ran the sink and just hurled
hurled into the sink. And I was like,
this is so ridiculous. Like there live,
I don't throw up but somehow or another
watching it on TV, you should, um,
you should isolate just the audio of that.
That fella totally sounded like
the GNARLIEST, sexy. Come on,
put it back in. You can win.
You can win it. Come on,
put it back yet they wouldn't even be
near your big black wouldn't even be
nearly the gnarliest. What's the
gnarliest sex shit you've ever seen?
That's really in the stumbling
department. I'm really careful. Like God,
I have a past with the trigger cause I
like what I like and I can't stand seeing
what I don't want. I don't like, you
know what I don't want to see. So I,
I've been really good
about, you know, yeah.
You have to in a certain surf around
on the specific sites where they're not
going to suddenly throw that stuff at me.
Like the New York city.com or something
like that. Or worldstar hip hop or no,
Dean de nyc.com I think is the worst.
It's one of the worst. Not Daily motion.
What's the one where there's lively,
lively, lively. It's got some dark shit.
Remember that we talked
about on one of the podcasts,
the girls with the high heels
and the kittens crushing,
they cannot hear about
calls with the high. Yeah.
I wouldn't want to ever see that. It's
more kittens don't need to be crushed.
Yeah. Kittens and puppies and
shit like that. All that stuff.
Talk to me about it. That's all that
faces a death kind of stuff too.
Like when people started describing it,
I'm just like,
I just totally tried to check out because
anything that I can kind of remember,
I'll access it at some point and he
freaked out by it again. You know,
it's good to know that it's out there
though. You don't want to be naive.
You don't want to think that people
aren't capable of fucking heinous acts.
Like I used to have a real
thing about serial killers, man.
I read a lot of books on serial killers,
a little watch,
a lot of documentaries and part of it
was just some morbid fascination by like
the ice man or you know,
a couple of other different ones like
John Wayne Gacy and Ed gain who used to
make lamps out of people and
dresses at a women's skin. You know,
when Gacy he was a clown,
he dressed up as a clown and fucked and
kills like a hundred kids and Bergen him
in his basement or
something insane like that.
Why hasn't there been a
comedian's Hillary or killer yet?
The problem has probably has no way it'll
will do. So like a known can be like,
you know, not, well, not super well known,
but well known enough to be able to do
the circuit tour and then, you know,
cause it,
cause the charter flight
for a serial killer would be
moving around all the time.
Charles Fleischer murders,
he's getting, he's got to go.
It used to be in all these towns, you
know, somebody eventually catch up to you,
I'd imagine. Do you remember that one
guy that got busted for rape? Yeah.
There was a guy who was a kind of a
serial rapist, do colleges and stuff.
Vince champ. That's his name. Yeah,
that was shocking as all hell
because he was one of those comics.
It was squeaky clean and all of his jokes
were about boogers and stuff and then
like, all right, and he's also a rapist.
That's the ones who are going to
watch out for like a guy like you.
You kind of put it all out there,
you know,
he didn't have to worry about
Doug Benson raping you. Yeah.
Those guys with those squeezy
says he's going to rape you.
You know it's on and you should
get reach for your car case.
I think that you know a person who's not,
you know who has like a
really suppressed act.
That's the bottles up inside
of you if you're a freak.
And a lot of these guys are, a lot of
the clean people are really freaky.
You know,
I've,
I know a lot of clean comics that go to
hookers and shit and do a lot of weird
deviant shit and their Sgo wiki
clean on stage. And I'm like,
it's almost like you need to blow
off that steam. It's like, you know,
you're onstage and you're so suppressed.
Like you can't wait to go to the dark
side as soon as you get the fuck away from
people. Man, when you see some guys
doing like a fucking a boat act,
he's one of those crews guys.
But it's really a, you know,
on the other hand it can
be marketable because
I think that as hilarious as they are,
they're two of my favorites.
Jim Gaffigan and Brian Regan, both
are squeaky clean and that, you know,
so families can go see them.
You know,
like I'll get the occasional weird
family comes to check me out. But like,
you know, I can't get all ages. You know,
I got a bunch of family people were a
guy with his kids that ran out of my show
in Toronto and I feel bad. I'm
sorry sir. I'm sorry. I did.
I can't change the act for your kids.
I didn't know you're going to bring 15
year olds and when they got up and split
like I was doing during what bit jokes
about fake babies getting their dick
sucked.
That was it. I was trying to let them
know it's not a real baby I made.
It's all in my act.
No real babies were blown during the
making of any of my material. Yeah. Yeah.
You got to say that right? You don't want
social services knocking on your door,
man. How'd you come up with is JB
blower? How'd you come up with this joke?
Um, but what were we talking
about? The led into this?
Did you drive around
this joke? Um, I forget.
I forget. You're talking on the side and
then like the talking about rape area.
Oh, squeaky clean. What happened? The
Toronto, the guy, the people in Toronto,
they just left and I heard about it later.
He was very upset.
Do you think he listens to this?
No. I'm sure he doesn't. Maybe.
I'm hoping they'll hear about, kind of
know that that sort of stuff comes up.
Yeah.
What do,
we were talking about what's clean
comic versus dirty comics that you could
bring your family to Gaffigan
show and to Brian Regan show.
But the difference is that's
how those guys really are.
Like Brian Regan is one of the nicest
guys I've ever met in my lightheart. Yeah.
And he's always been like that.
I've known Brian Regan since like 1992
or three I met him, I think I'm at,
I'm at the Montreal comedy
festival and he's always,
he never preaches about like, he
doesn't a lot of clean comics, you know,
hold it over your head. Like I can, I
can get big laughs without being dirty,
you know, like they make a big deal
out of it, but he never does that.
He's super nice about it. It's so
silly. That's so silly. Like, you know,
I had Africans got a dark side,
funny, funny Gaffigan does.
In what way? He just, you know, he, I know
he likes hearing and telling dirty jokes.
He's just chosen to be, could
be clean because it's, you know,
because he's good at it.
Oh, I see. He's hilarious.
It's almost like he's kind of forcing
himself to Barite funnier jokes because he
can't, you know, can't just throw in
random f bombs and stuff. That's true.
But I don't, you know, I think you can
do both. I want it all. I don't like,
I don't like rules. Like, yeah,
like j Morgan tweeted one day, uh,
you show me a comic with notes on stage
and I'll show you the summit in somebody
is not a real comic. And it's just
like, that's silly. You know what,
why can't you get notes?
It's a performance style.
Like if as long as the audience is getting
as many laughs, you know what I mean?
What difference does it make?
Well, you know, not only that,
what if you're working on some new shit,
it doesn't mean it's not ready.
It doesn't mean you have a
bunch of other shit to go to,
but there's a way to work on
some new shit and you know,
there's nothing wrong with having
some fucking notes up there, man.
As long as you're appreciative of the
audience's attention span and you're not
like, I don't like when people are
going through their nose. No, no, no.
It was not good enough.
Yeah. Yeah. I've seen some people do that
and I don't appreciate it as a comic,
I don't appreciate it. Forget about being
a person who actually paid to see it.
Yeah, but it's nothing wrong with
notes. I don't give a fuck what you do.
If it's funny, I don't care if you've got
a guitar. I don't care what you do, man.
I'm not.
I think it's silly all that you know
he's not a real this or you're not a real
that stop it. Stop it. Yeah.
I did and I don't know if it was Jay
Morris said that it might've been,
might've been carrot top lucky we didn't
go off on Jay more carrot top says that
to make props cooler, but at
least I don't have notes. Yeah,
you just have the joke
written on each prop,
afraid class that it was he picking up.
Somebody had a great point.
Who the hell was it? That
had a great point that he
destroyed a whole genre. Yeah.
There's no more prop comics. It's like
you have to be carrot top to do it.
It was Daniel Tosh, I credit Daniel
Tosh. We were hanging out, uh,
when we were doing the thing,
we were, Daniel tosh gets
punched by Manny Pacquiao.
I was his corner man. And I'll try to
talk him out of it. I'm like, do it.
Don't do it.
You're gonna get brain damage.
Get out of this guy's one of the greatest
ever and you've got to let them punch
in the face.
Are you fucking crazy?
So he goes out and it was pretty
funny and he did get hit pretty hard.
But tosh pointed it out and he's like,
there's no upcoming prop comes.
He used to be a genre, like when we were
open, Miker is used to be all that guy.
Oh, he's a guitar guy. Oh, that guy. He's
a prop guy. Did that prompt, got jugglers?
Magicians ventriloquists yeah,
like there's,
there's just one or none of all of them
now. Jeff Dunham's the Ventriloquist,
there's no famous juggler.
There's no guy that's like,
that's the guy that juggles,
which doesn't even exist anymore.
I wish Dunkin would
bring back little Hobo,
one of the greatest
ventriloquist hacks ever stolen.
Dunkin had a dummy called Little
Hobo and he used to close with it.
He had to close with it cause it was so
crazy and outrageous that there was no
room for it anywhere else. He had a,
he had a finished with it and he, uh,
somewhere where did it get
stolen from San Francisco.
We actually spoke to no room, a
no from a comedy club, but Martha,
fuck whoever you are, you piece of shit
actually talked to him. He was like,
you should do that again. That's a good
idea. And so he made an impression.
Yeah. Hey everybody. Hi.
That's a great idea. Hey Ari,
how's it going?
[inaudible] word is that an orange
wasn't cock sucker. What's
what the questions? Yeah.
Um, he's a, he's a great guy.
Dunkin and that fucking
puppet ACC was awesome.
He used to do this pink Floyd song. Have
you ever seen it? Ever seen his closer?
Oh my god,
it was genius.
This is genius about say tannic
puppet that killed his grandfather.
It's gotta be on Youtube
or, yeah, the gray.
What it is is the grandfather leaves
behind the puppet and the grandfather had
one wish that he wanted to
be buried with his puppet,
but he wanted Dunkin to go onstage
at the puppet the night before he was
supposed to be buried and just give
little Hobo one chance to say goodbye to
everybody.
So little hobos on stage with Dunkin
and little Hobo starts confessing to the
murder and then talking. It goes into
a trance and starts singing pink Floyd.
Wish you were here. They both sing at
the same time. It's fucking genius.
It's so good. And he's a
good ventriloquist. No, it's
terrible. So there's a secret,
but here's a secret. I can't,
I can't tell how he does it,
but it's really planned and the ending
is fucking awesome. It looks so, so good.
He couldn't follow it.
Yeah, he used to have to,
he used to have to close with it and I
used to always carried around in this
beat up suitcase. He's the,
he's one of my favorite people.
He's one of those dudes were,
no, he's going to come from
some weird fucking angle.
Like I could call Dunkin at three o'clock
in the morning and it'll go, dude,
I'm here watching ants in a death spiral.
Here's ants on youtube. And apparently
the fear Moans and some of the ants,
they're following a smell, but the queen
has died so they don't know where to go.
So they're all going out and they'll
go in that circle until they die.
Fuck far out,
man.
Those people you need in your life, man,
you have to cultivate them. That's like,
that's like the, the, the rare
flower that grew in tangled,
that kept mother Goethals alive. That's
what it's like. It's rare to find though.
It's good to have somebody that always
you, you know they're going to amuse you.
Yeah. You know, it's, it's a
nice experience to be like,
oh, I talked to this guy,
he's going to say something funny.
And that's what doctor drew doesn't
fucking have in his life and bring this
around full circle.
We're coming into the home front folks.
He's got so many comedians on his show
that all smoke on love line that I had
been on a bunch of times. I
don't know this, this clip is a,
I'm not saying it's not real, but
I'm just writing. I'm just wondering,
I'm not trying to start
any conspiracy theories.
You can Osama bin Ladin type shit
son. I still think that um, that it's,
he's kind of changed a little bit.
It's Kinda like, you know, Trump,
it's going to fall back on us.
All of his opinions or just the,
just a standard boiler plate.
What you should say to please the GOP
and he didn't used to feel any of those
things and you still like,
that's why you can't actually run,
cause they're going to dig up so much
stuff on him. It's just going to be like,
what are you, hold on. Newt Gingrich
thinks he can be president. You silly.
Fuck Newt Gingrich,
by the way,
was cheating on his wife while they were
having Clinton and parading him around
on television for being an adulterer.
Don't that whole time they were
going after Clinton impeaching him.
He was cheating on his wife.
Yeah, but that's, that's the,
that's what's changed is now they
can go after somebody about a birth
certificate cause they've
got one of those. Yeah.
They're not going to be a hypocrite.
Fuck the fuck man. I'm not a racist.
Newt Gingrich. You fucked up
dude. You can't be king. No,
you're going to have to accept
that. Go write books. Go be bitter.
Go drink at a bar somewhere and
tell people could have been,
but you can be really interesting to see
if the Republican's come up with like
their Obama if like somebody
really catches fire out of nowhere.
I know Sarah Palin's. Nice. Yeah. Really.
She loved the girl.
He yelled out.
My aunt is Sarah Pailin and I've got
an inside scoop because I met her.
That was the most obscure call back ever
two hours ago and I've no idea what was
happening then. I don't know who the fuck
is going to run for president, but I,
I would hope there would be at
least one option,
like a Gary Johnson or Ron Paul,
one person who has sense.
One person who represents moderate
people who just want to be left the fuck
alone, not this ridiculous battle of
left and right. That's not even a real,
there's gay marriage or gun control and
all these issues that they keep throwing
up that that's,
it's,
they're all giant distractions while
they rob you and fucking steal money left
and right. No matter what we do,
people are still going to have guns.
People are still going to get abortions,
but gay people are going to have
sex with each other for real.
People are gonna smoke weed.
You know what I'm saying?
All these things that they're fighting
so hard to stop are not going away.
Big Black Dick. When you realize
that, you know, we have everything.
There's people listening to
this podcast or drunk as fuck.
I pulled off the Joe Rogan drinking
game though. I do. Like I said,
I was going to do every time
Goldberg goes to take a pee, um,
I tell people to take a shot.
This is the Joe Rogan drinking game
because Mike Goldberg drinks a ton of Red
Bulls when we work together. And,
uh, you know, he's, you know,
he's fucking very professionally wants
to be hyped up and he has to pay all the
time.
The record for him peeing during a a
six hour broadcast is six times he gets,
I don't pee at all.
I sit down and sometimes if I can,
like if like there's a
break of like 20 minutes,
like there's been a bunch of
quick first round knockouts,
I'll get a chance and then I'll run,
take a,
take a leak and maybe even grab a quick
sandwich or something like that and then
sit back down again. Goldberg does it
all the time in the middle of the show.
So live on paper view. He runs to
the bathroom and then runs back.
So I told people that if you see the
fighter walking and the fact that music is
playing,
but I'm the only one talking take a shot.
Cause that means Goldberg's Peon and he
actually said it on the last paper view.
If you're playing the
drinking home game at home,
did Danny say anything about it?
That is always a good two,
three minute stretch
to go pee because yeah,
it's just a guy parading down
the middle of the, the island.
It's always exciting when you're there.
And there's also the conversations,
you know, like he's not gonna
be able to handle my power.
He's not gonna be able
to do with my speed.
This is a totally different kind of
athleticism. And then the other guy says,
you know, I got more experience. I'm
down, you know, I'm, I don't care.
I'm ready to go to war.
I'm going to die.dot, dot.
And the music plays and
walk up and the whole thing.
Doug Benson is a big UFC fan and
you went to a bunch of them. Yeah,
because it's like they show you,
they treat everything.
They do it just the right way they like,
and they show you everything you need to
know about each of the fighters on the
big screens.
Then they'd come in to their own music
that they've selected and they're all
pumped up. And you know,
in the case of Toronto,
there was a lot of Canadian fighters.
So the crowd was very much on the side
of the Canadian in each fight and,
but you just get so pumped up.
It's like seeing a trailer for an action
movie and then getting to see that
action movie right away instead of having
to go home and think about it like,
like they really set it up.
They really make you want to see these
guys fight and then you get to see them
fight.
And sometimes it's like amazingly quick.
And that in Toronto there was every
different kind of ending. If I could have,
you know, things went to a decision.
There was, there was knockouts,
there was a choke out. There was a boring
fight. Exciting fights. Yeah. Yeah.
It really was all
different kinds of fights.
Fights are important for two reasons.
One,
they make you appreciate the
exciting fights, you know,
because there's going to be fights and
there's going to be fights where guys,
it's not that they're not good, it's just
they cancel each other out, you know?
That's really all it is.
And sometimes when you got
guys that are equally talented,
it's a boring fucking fight,
especially when they're really good.
Grapplers like sometimes
just nothing happens,
but then the next fight will be some
crazy fucking head kick knock out and
you'll really appreciate
it. You know, just, yeah,
nothing more exciting than the guy that
actually ran up the chain link fence and
kicked a dude and the Anthony
Pettis that that they,
I see that clip every time I go
and it has, that is the most,
that is like movie shit that is,
that is only guys on wires making a
movie can do that. Not only did he do it,
he did it in the fifth round
of a championship fight
where it was neck and neck
up to that moment.
It was anybody's fight.
Literally up to that round he
was winning the whole round,
but up to that round it was anybody's
fight and he comes in with this crazy kick
and knocks him down. He's the greatest
kick I've ever seen in my life in Toronto.
That guy was it hammock that
had the had the Hematoma?
Yeah.
Somebody on Twitter said it passed.
It said it looked like a breast implant
right after we were like elephant man or
like it was horrifying.
It was a restaurant.
And right after I read breast implant I
was like God why didn't I think of that?
And he, but he almost came back
from that. He all, you know,
towards the end of the fight he really,
it was very exciting because prior to
that it was just watching a guy get
punched in his hematoma was,
it was brutal.
Well apparently Joe say Aldo had a
staph infection and that's why he looked
great in the beginning of the fight but
tired cause usually it doesn't tire.
He's a,
he's a fucking machine.
And I asked him about it after the fight
cause I knew he had a hard wait cut too.
But he in his corner,
apparently in Portuguese he said to one
of his corner men something about the
antibiotics. Like I should've taken more
antibiotics, has cornered, I said nothing.
You defend your title, you did a
great job, don't worry about it.
And then afterwards they said that he
had a staph infection and took an extreme
dose of antibiotics to try to cure it
as quick as possible, but thinks that,
you know, he didn't really, it wasn't
really 100% when he got in there. So,
which is amazing cause hammock is a really
bad ass dude and to be able to handle
harmonic while you're fucking sick from
antibiotics and a staph infection. Yeah.
Yeah. But that definitely explains
that last round. Like he really,
you talking back but it was too late
to, you know, to get the decision. Yeah.
He just kind of held on the last run.
He couldn't do anything.
And that's not like him at all. If you
look at his fight, like with Uriah Faber,
you're right favors of beats and he
beat the shit out of your Ira for five
rounds and he never got tired.
I mean it was just a, a beating.
It was a rye as a former champion
and he just could not fuck with all,
although it's just all over
him and he never got tired.
When you have a staph infection or if
you're on any kind of antibiotics like
that. I've had both. And
it's a draining thing.
It's your ads are going to be groggy
enough from getting hit in the face.
You don't need that extra. Yeah. Will
you be like Shitty, slow feeling weak.
Most people can't even
wrap their head around.
Would it be like to have to hit a bag for
25 minutes? You're fight five minutes.
Yeah. Five minute rounds.
Go hit a bag and the bag
doesn't even hit back. You would
drop dead of a fucking heart attack.
Like you have to be an incredible
condition to pull that off.
And then you add the fact that the other
guy's hitting you and then you have the
fact that you're wrestling and
then you add the fact that you're,
you're moving around and running
after each other and fuck.
And it's not a good time to be unhealthy.
Yeah, exactly. But sometimes these guys,
they're,
you know,
it's a title fight and there's a lot
on the line and like this weekend is a
perfect example.
Gray Maynard was supposed to have the
rematch with Frankie Edgar there for third
fight in the last fight was fucking
incredible. Just an amazing fight.
The first round gray Maynard knocked
Frankie Edgar down look at least three
times and he was badly fucking hurt.
It was crazy how it was
so close to being stopped.
He was getting fucked up and then he
won the second round and everybody went
crazy and then it looked like Edgar was
coming on and gray Maynard had blown
himself out trying to finish them in
the first round and it became a real
competitive fight and got down to a draw.
And so they're having a rematch.
It was supposed to be this weekend,
but gray Maynard or Frankie Edgar rather
broke his ribs or s something happened,
something happened.
He had a pullout and they were going
to offer gray Maynard Anthony Pettis.
But Maynard said, you know what? I've
got to tell you my knees fucked up too.
I was gonna. I was going to gut through
it just because it a title shot, you know,
because of the chance to, we've got
some time. So now he decided to step,
but it just goes to show that he's willing
to fight a fucking title fight with a
Jack Knee. You know, I mean
there's these guys, they, you know,
by the time they get through a
six to eight week training camp,
there's a lot of times they've got
some significant shit wrong with them.
You know, they're really
shows up in fights, you know,
fucked up knees, fucked up,
back's fucked up next.
Like Tiago Silva apparently fucked
as backup so bad that he had to take
something. I don't know what
the fuck he took, you know,
some sort of steroid or some
performance enhancing drug.
And he turned in like non human urine
and they tested his urine and they're
like, um, this is not
only is it free of drugs,
it's free of everything that would
make you a person from a Chinchilla.
You didn't get pregnant. She says you're
a Zombie. You know, but you know, it's,
it's uh, you know, being close to those
guys and being like, uh, you know,
on the road with them and going to all
these different towns and getting to see
them train and getting to see them fight
and getting to see good performances
and bad performances.
You're really wrap your head around what
a massive commitment it is to be an MMA
fighter and how fucking
easiest to be a comic.
It is. We're very blessed with
a whatever it is that, you know,
made us decide to do this because it's um,
you know,
and you can do it till
you die. I mean, people,
most people are as scared of getting
up and speaking in public as we are of
getting punched in the face.
I've done both and there's no comparison.
I was scared before I went on stage.
I was more scared than I was before
I would fight. Yeah, it's true.
It's amazing that difference. You
know, because that was only once,
once I did it and then I realized I was
like okay I was never in those cases
everyone would fight and everyone will
be a comic if both weren't scary. Yeah,
they're,
they're definitely
scary things. But it's just fun. It's
funny to me now like cause cause people,
I'll be sitting having a drink at the bar
right before I'm supposed to go on and
nobody would be like are you
nervous or do you have to prepare?
And it's just like not really. I'm
even drinking and smoking weed outside.
Like I just go out there and you know,
I haven't done a show where people
wanted their money back cause I was too
fucked up. But you know it's,
it's a, it is an easy thing
to do if you know, if you,
if you do it all the time. Joey Diaz
says it best. He says the hardest,
easiest thing you'll ever do. Yeah.
And that's really what it is. Once you,
once you get it,
once you're locked in and if you're
in the groove it's super easy.
But if you're out of the groove,
like if you go up in a bad state of mind,
like have you ever had like
a real, like you go, fuck,
I shouldn't have gone on stage. I
should've, I should've tooken a night off.
Have you ever had where you were
emotionally kind of in a bad place? Yeah.
Like you know,
I maybe a little more prone to snap at
people for being douchey in the audience
because you know, it just wasn't
in the right, you know, I kind of,
I'll go into it sometimes a
little negative like, oh, okay,
I could tell this was going
to be a noisy crowd and the,
and I'll let it get to me
when I could just, you know,
try to ignore it, you know?
No, but I'm, what I mean is like,
have you ever had a where
you're emotionally fucked up,
you just went up there and
you just couldn't be funny
and just weren't funny and
just couldn't feel it because I don't know
why you, you're talking about, no, no,
but I'm ridiculous like that. I can, I
can understand that that happening. Like,
I certainly,
but it's not you.
I didn't do standup comedy for
like a week after nine 11. Like I,
that was a period of time
where like if I went on stage,
I just feel like it would feel wrong and,
and uncomfortable.
But fortunately people didn't want comedy,
you know what I mean?
They waited a little bit. But then
once, once I got back on board,
it was a great feeling
to make people laugh, uh,
under those circumstances. You
know, it was like, it was a good,
it was therapeutic for me
and the audience. Right.
But you've never had a moment where you
were in a shitty place and you went on
stage and because of you being in
a shitty place, he just ate it. No,
I just eat it on my own and
then, and then, you know,
they'd get mad at them if they don't like
it, but I, I can't really blame it on,
you know, like I'd imagine that
there's, there's gotta be some sort of,
are you hinting it?
Have you had an situation that,
I've had a couple of the best ones
I've ever heard. Those are into,
something would happen to Ari. Ari
Ari had a girlfriend that uh, he uh,
was upset that she was hanging out at
the comedy store after they broke up.
It was really upset how they broke up
and it just, it was, it was hard on him.
This is a heartbreaker and she was hanging
around the comedy store and he threw
a glass of ice water on her head and
everybody got mad at them and there was
like, dude, you know what
the fuck? And then our,
he tries out for last comic standing and
this girl is one of the judges for last
comic standing.
I was wondering if it was her and there's
only three people in when the last
comic standing judging is really
not stand up comedy really never.
There's never any other situation where
you have to do standup for three people
in a room. And if there is, you
should, you should run. Yeah,
it's gross the way they do it is
gross. I don't agree with it. I think
it's cruel.
It's cruel bee.
A little melodramatic. It's weird.
It's weird. It's weird. Weird.
It doesn't have anything to do with like
becoming a stand up comic and they can,
or being a good one. The eight K
it's influenced by Simon Powell.
I was there for last comic standing,
the original, the original series,
the first season rather I was one of
the judges and when we judge comics,
they were in front of a crowd and they
got a crowd to perform in front of and we
voted them in or out
and it was that simple.
Then somewhere along the line they got
the sort of Simon cowel thing going on
where they want to see
the shitty additions,
they want to see the shitty auditions
and they want to interrupt people and be
funny,
like cutting them off.
And so Aria has no idea that she's one
of the judges and he goes out there and
just was totally unprepared and didn't
know what and just ate shit and just dry
brick.
Plonk
plonk that's the worst one I've
ever heard. My worst one was, uh,
I was in a gas station on my way to the
comedy store and it was two weeks after
Phil Hartman had died.
And I hadn't gotten on stage yet and I
was the first time going on stage back
and Nope,
no,
it was the second time I'd gone on
stage the night before and it went okay.
But it was shaky, you know, but I was,
I was thrown and I knew that people when
they are introduced me say that he's on
news radio. I knew the people in
the audience are going to go, oh,
it was not there where that guy got
murdered by as quite of your top of mind
problem. And it's why I blew,
blew her brains out and he's
a big fucking story. Um,
and so I'm on my way to the comedy store
and I pull into the gas station and
it's dude that I knew from Jujitsu is
a cop and he sees me and we started
talking and he tells me that he was there
and he tells me that his buddy broke
into the house because Phil Hartman's
wife had the kids in the bathroom and she
had a gun and she had already killed
fill and she was going to kill the kids.
And that's what you know,
that's what a mother does.
If a mother is going to commit suicide,
a lot of times if they're,
they're that desperate and they're
that fucked up, they were about to go,
they're going to kill her kids to it.
They didn't want the kids.
So the guy kicks down the door because
they know that she's got a gun and the
kids run away from their mother.
They run from their mother pulling away,
screaming,
run from their mother.
They get out of the bathroom and she
blows her fucking brains out. Boom.
Cops in the house, kids running from
her and she blows her brains out.
And I went on stage an hour later
and there was no way I can be funny.
It was impossible. It was impossible.
And I was saying the jokes right,
I was, I was trying, the words were
coming out in the correct order,
but there was no way I could be funny.
It was, it was, there was nothing there.
And I, even at the end of the
show, I said something, I said,
I'm sorry I shouldn't have got onstage.
I found out some shit right before I
went on stage and I couldn't not think
about it when I was up here and I
apologize is terrible side. I'm sorry.
I'm just bring up the next
guy and hopefully he won't
suck as bad and I brought
up the next guy and I just fucking
got out of there. Drove home crying.
That was, that was the
worst. That's intense.
Yeah. I'd wished that guy wasn't
there at that gas station.
I really didn't want to know
that. Yeah, yeah. No, that's,
that's way too much. Yeah,
and I'm not high anymore. Yeah.
That's a buzz kill, right? Wow.
We'll have to fire back up. Five 21 oh
it's the end of the show. What a downer.
Should we end on this downer? Do you have
anything happen? Oh, that's pretty heavy.
Shoot yourself up tonight at sounds.
Comedy Hall or not.
Maybe we're just going to carry that
thought. I'm going to be in mom tonight.
I'm going to be sorta near the White House
and somebody is asking me if I wanted
to do a tour of it. Whoa. And I'm like,
do they let people use the bathroom
and the White House? I don't know.
I'd love to take a shoe thing. There's
cameras in the, in the bathroom,
in the White House.
That'd be weird.
What do you mean has to be on stage
as I'm trying to stall would get,
I would imagine there has to be cameras
in the bathroom of the White House.
Even in like while you're
sitting on the crapper,
I think there has to be cause you
otherwise you can be, you know,
you could go in there and take off your
jacket and start putting together a gun
that you've got pieced of little, little
tiny parts all throughout your jacket.
You screw it together.
You're went out and ice everybody.
I think you have to go
through a metal detector day.
Give you maybe have a plastic gun
first place, maybe a plastic gun.
Your boat with a man. I have some sort of
special metal. It doesn't get detected.
Maybe picked my fucking watch doesn't go
off when I go through my wedding ring.
My watch is this.
I could make something out of this
watch and fucking cut you open with it.
This is ridiculous.
It's metal.
Well it's some metals that works and some
metals that doesn't all the TSA rules
right.
Drive me crazy cause I just like,
like you can have lighters in
your checked bag. I mean in your,
in your carry on but you can't
have lighters in your checked bag,
which that doesn't make any sense to me.
I fly with a lot of lighters
cause you know how I am
either people or giving them to me
like as a present or I'm just actually
walking away with people,
lighters and I,
so I always have a bunch of my bag
coming back from Canada, from Toronto.
They pulled me aside and said you've
got too many lighters and I was like too
many. And they go, yeah,
you can only have one.
And so they made me throw
out like four lighters.
But it was really funny because he's like
you have too many letters and they're
like yeah there might be a couple in
there. And they were like, here's one,
here's what they're like
pulling all these liners out.
And one of them was a Mary Louise Parker.
It was like a one of those flip lighters,
you know the a and M had a picture of
Mary Louise Parker looking all sexy from
weeds on it and then,
and engraved in the back,
some stuff about you're
such a great stoner when it,
and the guy stood there in
front of me and read it.
He read it and then he's like, well,
which one do you want to keep? And I said,
I'll,
I'll keep that one.
I'll keep doing what the engraved one
and I threw away for stupid bics or
whatever. But uh, what, what
does that, what are those,
why are those rules different
from country to country?
Like they should just be standards that
are set up and they should, you know,
make some sort of sense because Hannah
has got a lot of interesting rules.
You can't even get in there if you have
a Dui. Really when they run your Id,
if you have a Dui, they say you can't
come into the country. Sorry, Douche bag.
That's not a bad idea.
It's great idea.
It's one of the reasons why Canada is so
fucking cool. I had no idea though that,
I mean I don't have a Dui but uh,
if I had one I would have
still tried to go to Canada.
Like you don't find out to get
there. Right. Yeah. Thank you.
Can make your reservations and stuff.
We'll even if you get off of something
sometimes it shows up on your record.
Eddie Bravo had a gun charge cause he
got pulled over once and he was legally
carrying a gun cause he worked for
a check cashing company and uh,
he told the cop, you know,
you have to tell a cop, a cop
pulls you over. I'm sorry.
Just tell you officer, I have a
loaded gun. So they handcuff him,
throwing the back of the car. They run
his plate, they run the whole thing. Okay.
You're legally carrying his
gun, go back to work, take care.
But that just the fact that he was
arrested shows up and every time we go to
Canada I said get away from me dude.
You go up there on your own
because if I get stuck with them,
I'm stuck for fucking hours. Man. Stuck
for an hour and a half, two hours.
We tried to drive across the
border with Tommy Chong runs
from uh, from Seattle into
Vancouver and they just, you know,
they searched the car within an
injured dog. That car got so raped.
It was a,
it was a long stretch limo too.
So it was kind of embarrassing like how
many you seats and stuff they had to
pull out, but they were super
friendly to him the whole time.
Never searched any of our bodies like a,
you know,
we've realized after we left
that to one of my friends,
Tony had a joint in his
pocket the entire time until,
wow. Those kinds of moments
are just like he would,
if he didn't know he had it on him,
he wouldn't have been able to pull it off.
Yeah, right. He just said he just
thought he didn't have any weed on him,
so they were like, get out of
the car or come stand over here.
And we're just saying, we just
stood around and they'd, you know,
they ran all of our
passports and so again,
lucky I didn't have a DUI
and that's how much that we,
that guy smokes kind of like unknown
joints and get out of his body.
Let me what my book bag I,
I traveled last time I traveled I had
a bowl and weed in it from Portland
because so many fucking people
gave us weed and it Joey d is,
is putting weed in my book bag.
Everyone who's given me weed and
you that at the airport and got a search
your shit for weed before you fly. Yeah.
Don't be putting weed
in your luggage ever.
You're not going to find weed my luggage
to go ahead and look a little bit.
I'm just saying just because it's my
understanding that it fits in your checked
bag. Like if you put it in a sock
or something that uh, you know,
the worst is going to happen is the guy
who finds it just takes it for himself.
Really. I wouldn't try that shit
going to Canada. No, no, no, no.
Not Out of the country. I'm talking
domestic. I still wouldn't try that shit.
It's not worth it. No, it's, it's
smart not to and you're beautiful.
You're lucky like me.
You go somewhere and make one phone call
or something or write one tweet and the
find out where the weeds at.
Yeah.
You find out where the cops are at
third tweet and hey man, come meet me.
My Burger King cops so don't care.
There's no sting operations for existing
operations for high school, Bro.
Like us. Don't. They don't ever harass
us is what I'm saying. That's true.
But how many dudes in high school were
gone, Bro? You're fucking paranoid.
These people are not undercover
cops. Meanwhile, they were,
could you imagine they were
getting high and they go, dude,
I think Billy's an undercover cop.
Get the fuck Outta here man.
No undercover cops. This is high school
in Florida. Nobody gives a fuck man too.
I'm telling you for 40 year olds just
transferred into our school and it turns
out they all really need weeds.
How we're going to help
them out because you know,
it's hard to be 40 and in high school and
need weed. Yeah. Meanwhile, by the way,
Florida is like the number one
pill place in the whole country.
It's the easiest place to get pills.
We've talked about it before and
we'll bring it up again for it.
It doesn't have a database.
You can get oxycontin's all over the
place in Florida because you can get a
prescription and it didn't go down
the street to another doctor and say,
my back hurts.
And he writes you another prescription
and you go to another doctor.
You can keep doing it all over Florida.
People do it all the time.
There was a vanguard show and
episode of, uh, uh, called, um,
the oxycontin express all about, you
can find it online if you're interested.
Just, just Google the oxycontin
express and it's all about the law.
The hard words to spell and
you're telling me boxy content.
We'll just throw it in Google.
It will say, did you mean this?
And it'll clear you up. But uh,
yeah, man, pills are a lot more,
more fucking now.
I kept one commercial that the drug free
America did where they showed like the
dealer on the corner talking
about will you should,
you know you should keep your kids away
from the medicine cabinet before you
keep him away from me. Like that should
be a bigger concern. Yeah, no shit.
Cause it's right there under their
noses and you're gone all the time.
I'm getting, you know, he's like,
I'm not going to be out of business
because of drug medicine cabinets. I wish,
I wish we could get
through the doctor drew
that if Dr Jay was talking about this
kind of, if he's taught, call him up.
I was talking about,
but this is going after narcs that are
arresting high school kids for we'd look,
I don't know why he thinks
that's a good idea. First of all,
when you're a high school kid, yeah,
you're going to make shitty choices.
You're gonna make bad decisions.
You're in high school and if
you're selling going to try stuff,
you're supposed to take the wheat
away from the kid and go stop.
You're not supposed to have undercover
cops pretending to be students wandering
the halls trying to buy weed.
They should be.
And they should be trying to stop
adults from selling stuff like that to
children. That's what they should, that's
what they undercover thing should be,
is they should pretend to be dealers and
get involved with those other dealers.
And, and that's, yeah, it's a minor
them out. Weeds, a minor issue folks.
The real issue is pills and heroin and
meth and all that creepy shit that ruins
limes. Weed's not ruined your life.
It's just not, I don't buy it.
I didn't even start until I was in my
late twenties. I was 30, 30 years old,
almost 31. Yeah. And I never, when
I was a kid, I never was loud.
I was like a big fan of Cheech and
Chong, you know, had their albums,
listen to them and never even thought
to try it. It just seemed like, oh,
it's fun laughing about this. Uh, you
know, he's crazy. He had dug adult.
What got you to take her other
comics really sane improves. Really.
So did they like talk you into it or
did they say did you want to try it?
They're just like lets smoke, smoke
some pot. And they were both into it.
So I was like I'll give it a,
you know,
I'll give it another world because I
was one of those same thing happened to
Willie Nelson supposedly where like
the first time I tried it once in high
school I was like one of those
people have walked around and going,
oh it didn't do anything, you
know, didn't do anything for me.
So you know with Shitty weed or
I didn't already has a friend.
We're legitimately doesn't work.
Yeah.
I've seen him smoke crazy amounts of
weed and nothing happens or it doesn't do
anything. Yeah. But Michael Michael,
Ian Black is like that. Really? Yeah.
Cause he said I really want to
get high, get me high. And I was,
we were in Seattle so I had good weed
and I watched him smoke a ton of it and
then he was just like, no, nothing.
You haven't tried to use it
because it's a bit like, you know,
you're pretending that you're
not high. And, uh, I don't
know if he's done edibles.
I don't know if he's tried that.
I'll ask him sometime. But he, yeah,
he's kind of like just a, he's just
built a certain way that he doesn't,
it doesn't affect him.
So did you go right from being a guy who
never smoked weed to just fucking full
on stoner? I was know as Moochy
Moochy admin for a long time.
Like I only smoked when it was
around, you know what I mean? Like I,
and I hung around a lot of comics,
so they hooked me up a lot, you know?
And I think that at a certain point I
started to think, oh, I should contribute,
you know, because this is just rude
and I'm smoking more, you know,
I want my own and I want to be able
to share and, and so then I, you know,
but I think when did you first ramped up?
Pretty quickly?
I think just because of being on
the road all the time. You know,
this was when I was like a feature act.
So what year is this we're talking about?
I have no idea.
I could
trying to get at was La,
was it,
you'd have to buy pot from dealers or
are you going through the medical system?
No, I had dealers it medical system. He
hadn't started yet. And then once it did,
it took me years to catch on.
Like I didn't get involved in
the medical system until, uh,
making super high me really,
because I always,
I always had good dealers that were like,
you know,
I had this one guy that would
just drive it right to my house.
You'd always just get whatever you get.
Like he just give you an eighth of
something awesome. But, uh, you know,
and it was pricey, but I was working, you
know, it was working and could afford it.
And so it was never really, like, for
the first few years of medical marijuana,
I knew some people that were like, oh,
you gotta do it. It's amazing. But like,
until you step into one of those
places you really don't get.
And that's part of what I love to show in
that in the movie Super Jaime, is that,
you know, people in other states are
just blown away that, that, that,
that exists and that you just
go in there and shop for.
We'd like that in such a
relaxed environment. I know,
it's amazing. And um, yeah,
so, um, but once I got
into the medical thing,
now I'm really into that. But, but
prior to that I just had a, you know,
different dealers, you know, one that got
robbed and kind of hurt one time that,
that kind of sucked, you know, like
really? Yeah. I mean I definitely,
once I figured out about medical, I
was happy to make the leap, you know,
because I think people that
are dealing or just like,
they're taking too many
risks, you know? That's,
that's my leading thing about legalizing
marijuana is just the incarceration of
people that have anything to do with
it. You know? That's, that's like,
that's where I think that's the main
thing I'd like to see happen first because
with medical marijuana and Arnold
Schwarzenegger and making it a like a
misdemeanor citation, a bull offense, uh,
I'm not too worried
about getting to smoke.
I don't really need it to be
legal for my own personal sake.
I want it to be legal for the,
you know, the black guy that get,
gets pulled over and has some in
his pocket. Right, right. Yeah.
Well it is decriminalized
now in this state. Yeah.
And now the gym is like a hundred
dollar ticket or something. Yeah.
If the bigger ticket, if you
smoke a cigarette, really Burbank,
it's a suburb and it's like a two
or 300 Burbank is above the law.
Burbank's robots do it.
A lot of crazy stuff.
Why show Sunday at flappers
at four 20. Oh, that's right.
Let's wrap it up with that. That Joe Rogan
might might appear. I'm going to try,
I'm going to try to make it, cause
I think I land that morning. Um,
I'm pretty sure. All Right
Ladies and gentlemen, that's it.
That's the on the podcast tonight,
we are going to be at Sal's comedy whole.
Did you get this? If you're in
la, go to sales comedy whole dot.
Come and work your way through
that shit hole of a website.
So you find the reservation page and
click on some link and I think you can
enter in a credit card or something
that went there at eight o'clock.
It's small place, but it'd be Doug
Benson, Sam Tripoli, Thompson, Gora.
Um,
this weekend,
Sam triply and Thompson Gora and me are
at Cobbs and that's three headliners,
man and Salmon, Sam. And I'm a Thompson.
We're at both fucking hilarious
if you never seen them before.
So it should be a killer show,
like four and a half headliners.
I think I liked the way you think.
Um, the Saturday night is sold out.
I think there's just a couple of tickets
left Friday and a couple of tickets
left Thursday as, as far as the
beginning of this podcast, uh,
it might all be sold out. We'll see you
guys there. And, um, uh, next week, uh,
I'm going to be doing a
movie, so no podcast. And, uh,
so I'm going to try to get some people
from the movie and on the podcast I'll
try to interview them and Bas Rutten's
going to be there and maybe interview him
again too. But, uh, I'm gonna do
my best to get you guys some shit,
but there won't be any Ustream ones.
So that's it.
And we go a live on serious May 28th. So
a, that's it. All right. It's working.
Show's over. I love you bitches. Sure.
Okay.